good morning everyone and can i welcome
everyone to this meeting of development
control committee at mid-south district
council just need to run through before
we start some of the domestic
arrangements
can i please ask you to ensure that you
maintain social distancing from other
persons while in the chamber and in the
communal areas please ensure that you
wear a face covering at all times unless
you're sitting down or of course if
you're exempt from doing so and then
please use hand sanitized hand
sanitizers and wipes
that have provided
please ensure that your microphones are
turned off when you're not speaking and
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations while
others are speaking if you're attending
the meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave can i just ask everyone to
double check your mobile phones are
pleased on silent or
switched off
um
we will be using e-voting today for this
meeting which is on the modern.gov dot
sorry modern.gov app
so can i ask members just to make sure
they're logged on and ready to use the
app for when we come to attendance and
voting
i'd like to remind everyone present this
meeting is being broadcast live on the
internet and will be capable of repeat
repeated viewings and the whole of the
meeting will be recorded except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to consent it to having been recorded
and by entering this meeting as a
speaker you're also consenting to being
recorded by the council into the
possible use of those sound recordings
for webcasting and or future training
purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting
when the public press are not lawfully
excluded
if you hear the
fire alarm ring it's not a
practice today so can you please leave
the building immediately via the fire
exit and make your way to the assembly
point which is at the ipswich town
football club next door please follow
the signs directing you to the fire
exits which are located at each end of
the floor please do not enter the atrium
area the ground floor and the walkways
and if you are in the atrium please
follow the signs to the nearest exit
please use the stairs and do not use the
lifts and do not re-enter the building
until we're told it is safe to do so
good so that's all that done so we'll
just move on just for the benefit of the
members of the public
who are here today welcome thank you for
joining us just who's going to do what
just uh you made this maybe your first
development control meeting
so my i'm matthew hicks uh and i'm with
my colleagues here on the uh this side
of the chamber are the elected
councillors who make the decisions on
the applications before us today
a member in mid-suffolk may not vote on
an application in their own ward so for
that occasion they will join
peter gould whose accounts are sitting
over there
so that they do not
have the opportunity to vote on
applications in their own area
other introductions just running around
the room quickly we have ian de prez
who's here for our legal advisor
john paytman g who's the area planning
manager
we have other planning managers also
present other planning officers also
present so welcome we have sue hooton
here to help us on some ecology
questions and then the people that keep
the meeting running ticking and running
on time are the important people to my
right and my left and at the back who
just keep things running smoothly so
welcome
we'll now move straight on to the agenda
first item is apologies for absence and
substitutions do we have any apologies
to abstinence please
[Music]
thank you chair we have apologies from
councillor sarah mansell and councillor
barry humphries
councillor roland warboys is
substituting for councillor mansell and
councillor david byrne is substituting
for council of humphreys thank you
thanks very much do we need to receive
any decorations of pecuniary or
non-pecuniary interest by members
none received thank you
any declarations of lobbying
um
i was yeah
okay on
which one
yeah
yeah and we had the eye previously as
well okay
yeah cancer was any uh
okay thank you very much
okay so they're all non-pecuniary
interests thank you
and sorry they're all decorations we
start again we've all been lobbied
appropriately but it's all recorded
thank you decorations of personal site
visits so we've got a need to declare
no none thank you okay um next item with
gender item five's confirmation the
minutes of the meeting held on the 18th
of august 2021
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes that members
wish to
[Music]
bring up could i have a proposal for the
minutes then please
thank you council passport under
secondary cancer field thank you
governor's officers will now conduct an
electronic vote
thank you chair members if you go to the
plus sign in the top right hand corner
of your modguv app
this boat is now in progress
thank you members chair that's five
votes for and two abstentions
okay thanks very much the minutes of the
meetings have now been confirmed and i
will sign them later okay gender item
six to receive notifications of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme are there any
non-received chair okay thank you um so
we move on to the schedule of planning
applications before us today um just for
the record application dc 2005
has been withdrawn from this meeting uh
just so that everyone's in case there's
anyone here waiting for that application
okay so we'll move straight on to the
first one which is uh dc
210329 6 cross street in i i'd like to
invite the case officer alex scott to
introduce the application to committee
please
yes thank you chairman um
members as uh champions explain this is
uh item
agenda 7a in your papers application
reference dc forward slash
21 0 3 6 2 9
6 cross street in i
and the application before you is the
use of the
existing office building as parish
meeting room
in addition to uh of the office space
the erection of a front entrance canopy
construction of solar pv panel array to
the roof
and with associated landscaping and
parking
now the applicant is mid-suffolk
district council which is why the
application is before
us today
and the aims of the proposal are to the
creation of lettable office space for
small businesses
and new startup businesses the provision
of uh dedicated itan council office
space
and to provide sustainability
improvements to the building so just
move to the presentation
and the site location of i within the
district for the avoidance of doubt um
the approximate location of a site
within the town and surrounding area
a wider aerial view of the town and site
for you
and a closer aerial view
showing the location
and this is a constraints map
and the site is fully within the
settlement boundary of the town allies
uh just outside of the town conservation
area which is that purple hatched area
you can see there
and all the coloured buildings there are
listed buildings of various grades
this is the site location plan an
existing site layout provided with the
application
and some site photos of the
building as existing and the adjacent
library recently constructed
existing elevations of the building
existing floor plans and roof plans of
the building
the existing street scenes
and this is the proposed site layout
it shows
parking bays
constructed to um
disability um scale so they would be
suitable for use for disabled persons
it's also a bike shelter proposed
immediately behind it with three uh
like spacers and also electric uh bike
uh charging uh ability they're proposed
as well
and you can see the uh solar pv panels
to the uh south wrist float also
proposed
these are the proposed elevations
showing all the
list of
improvements those are in your papers
and proposed rear and side elevations
the proposed floor space now the yellow
area indicates the area proposed for use
by the town council the purple areas um
additional office space i believe those
there are six of those
um and downstairs
and the blue is a shared meeting room
there's also
external uh space available at the back
secure bin storage
and uh air source heat pump which is
part of the sustainability measures
proposed
this is what's proposed upstairs in
terms of additional office space
and the roof plan again showing the
solar pv panels to the south facing roof
slope
uh proposed street scene elevations as
well there
um as in your papers officer
recommendation uh for approval subject
to conditions thank you chad
thanks very much do we have any
questions for the case officer to
yeah council eben
thank you very much chair um i've got
several questions if i may there's been
various comments about the parking
taking up
existing parking can you just clarify
whether the
um parking spaces
were previously
that that area of land was previously
allocated to this building or was in
was part of a another
car parking area
secondly
disability access there doesn't seem to
be any at all really in terms of people
for people with disabilities could say
could you just clarify that
um and
thirdly the
um
it's not clear from the papers and maybe
it doesn't need to be about why we need
so many offices there and was
consideration given to having affordable
housing or of you know flats upstairs
instead or whatever um um is there an it
is there a need for these
you know mini office block in the middle
of eye thank you very much
um yes uh thank you council reba um
first of all the parking um there's uh
area hard standing within the
site ownership to the front uh i believe
that was uh available for use when the
building was uh previously occupied as
officers by suffolk county council
it may have been used
casually by other users in the interim
however it is associated with that
building
in terms of um disability we have uh
consulted the um mid-suffolk disability
forum as part of the application i
believe and uh
there are certain improvements um in
terms of ramped access um although there
are comments that internal layout could
be could be better
but
that's not necessarily for planning
that's for
future occupants to
to discuss
in terms of affordable housing um
yes it's not something i was aware of
it's not something that necessarily your
officers have looked at in terms of this
particular application
but i will say that the building has an
existing office use um
therefore it could be used
as as proposed in in the main uh without
uh
needing change of use uh planning so
hopefully that's helped thank you
thank you yes
council madison
um
yeah the the um
i think the first question really is
the um
how much what the
kilowatt capacity of the photovoltaics
will be and
is there going to be battery backup
um and also closely related
i wonder whether we might
be able to get some sort of um
heritage
look
um panels i know there are better and
worse and we i think we made a little
progress a few years ago and getting
um ones that were black rather than ones
with aluminium frames
shining off them um
and um
you know related questions to that
that's my first one
do you want to give do you want to give
them have you got another one follow up
was
quite different and that was about the
the issues that have been
raised by many many
objectives regarding the parking the
wider parking issues and i wonder
whether
um
there is
there is um any measurable evidence
about that
um that's that's been brought to play
and i did want to actually just ask the
chair whether um anybody is going to
appear on behalf of the applicant
yep we have the we have uh the i town
council here we and then the ward member
no other speakers
uh thank you chair um yes thank you
council matheson um in terms of the
kilowatt uh capacity and battery backup
i don't have that information to hand
specifically but we do have the yes yes
we do have so maybe when the applicants
are speaking that could be a question
that could be raised there um
in terms of the heritage look of the
panels
[Music]
we have recommended a condition for the
precise detail to be submitted
so there's is the opportunity for that
to come
forward when heritage looked at this
they did think that there was an
opportunity to have some better look
panels so um we can ensure that the best
quality in terms of the setting of
heritage assets
is is provided so there's the
opportunity to come back on that yeah
john just tell you
since the since my notes were done we
have got the applicant here who is going
to speak
thank you
and in terms of the wider parking issues
yes
noted in the report and we have received
several
responses from members of the public
with with concerns
there is a provision for
increased parking in the neighborhood
plan i understand but
[Music]
in terms of this
this planning application um
the uh proposed provision is considered
um suitable for the um existing building
and there is um
uh additional parking in the uh
the public car park adjacent however the
comments in terms of capacity are noted
the applicant later thank you
thanks very much another yes council of
war poisoning cancer field
uh
it's another parking related
question i'm afraid on on slide eight
um
if you'd like to put it up this is just
photographs of the
the queen's head
and the parking
that off we could go
that's the one yes
there's quite a lot going on
um to the side of the building which is
a site which is occupied by
the parking which is going to go with
the building there's
there's bins there i can see barrels in
the background and one of the letters
objecting was
that the
um
parking been allocated there is going to
affect deliveries to the queen's head
has that actually been
um investigated as it were would we
actually be restricting
their access
i presume those bins are to do with the
queen's ed or are they to do with the
president-empty officers
um well the um the red line plan if i
can just uh
go back to that
yes um so i think you can see there the
uh
the red line associated with this uh
application um
and uh the access available
to
the queen's head
at the back there um
yeah it's not considered that um
the the parking provision would uh in
any way impede that
however it is noted that uh there are
there is informal parking in that area
and uh
the use of bins you know i would say
that's a uh
you know a psych ownership issue and
access issue uh john please john you
want to come in
i think um probably just come in here
and just clarify a couple of pieces with
this particular application um
ultimately
that land is in the ownership of the
applicant as i understand um and there
is obviously an informal arrangement
that the bins and so on have been placed
on that land there is nothing stopping
the owner of the land simply saying
don't put that stuff on my land and
clearing it you know this is an informal
arrangement so far
ultimately the applicant and the
application before you is not to use
that is to put forward the car parking
on the land instead um but then i said
there's nothing stopping them just
taking the bins and other people's
elements that of use off that land and
restricting it and clearing it
before us as well we need to be very
careful about this office use
the current building is as i understand
it an office use
internally we have no control in
planning they can subdivide this
building as many times as they want and
make as many officers out of this
building as they so wish
this does not require any kind of
consent that is not exactly what's
before us
therefore we need to be careful about
the knock-on parking requirement
because of what you can do under
permitted development versus what's
before us in terms of the external uh
alterations proposed does that help yeah
thank you for that
councillor
field you were next
thank you it's just a question really
about the accessibility the disability
um
um considerations and this building i'm
not really clear you didn't make a
comment about an external ramp but is
that provided or not provided is it
a dream or an actual intention
um i know one of the
was its three kitchen areas is labeled
as accessible and one of the toilets but
could you just make it clear to what
extent does this go along this
development go along with the
requirements of the
disability experts
in terms of the um
comments was received from the
disability forum i think they were
generally um
generally satisfied with the proposed
provision and from what i can see there
was a comment about um
internal accessibility to certain office
space you know could be better um and
they've requested that but um
suddenly it was felt
improvements on the uh on the existing
layout i really
got that feeling
are the doors the right width for
wheelchairs is there a ramp outside i
know there's a comment that you can't
put a lift to the first floor
many people put stair lifts in just what
yeah
john we've got there are we going we've
got the applicant here as well if we
haven't got that detail if you want to
ask them
get the finer detail yes i think a
detailed question for the application
yeah can i can i just come in on that
one if i do if i may so in terms of
is it possible to put the elevations
back on screen
the
front entrance
appears to be level with the path as
shown on the elevations is that correct
so the need for a ramp i'm not clear on
that in terms of so on page
45 of your papers that's the
existing so we're not changing the front
entrance
there's no ramp
so the proposed elevation of my
apologies uh is on page 47
that appears to be a level access
arrangement
i think
and if it isn't it's only what's shown
on here and that should be secured if
members wish to secure it as a level
entrance way
for disabled users
beyond that the internal arrangement we
can encourage
doors wide enough for disability and
there are other walls regulations that
someone has to follow but
ultimately we can't entirely control
what people do to their internal
works thank you councilman there
it's already gone about parking can we
have slide eight again please
yeah it's the one showing the pub
in there somewhere
now am i right i'm saying there are
double yellow lines down the side of the
existing building
that appear to go through what we're now
told is land owned by the council
so suffolk county council at one point
thought
no parking at any time and now we're
putting parking spaces there
just seems to be a confusion
those to the left
or do those yellow double yellow lines
stop i think they stop but we can check
with the applicant just a confusion
thank you
well the the town council will know we
can ask them
yeah cancer possible thanks um matthew
just a very quick point of information
if you look at one of the plans that we
have earlier there is a large car park
actually to the left of the building as
you look at it and i think people need
to understand that and perhaps the ward
member and applicant would be able to
clarify that um and plus um the comments
about the double yellow line it might be
useful to hear them
earlier rather than later okay well on
that note we will move on uh so we'll
now move on to the public speakers
first up i'd like to invite the
representative of i town council to
speak councillor richard berry and you
have three minutes we do keep you to
three minutes and the time is here
whenever you're ready thank you chair uh
good morning councillors uh i'd like to
start by placing this proposed
development within the context of the i
neighborhood plan
this is now formally adopted after a
referendum and one of the key vision
statements is that i should become and i
quote from the document a green town
with community projects to encourage
green energy and conservation
it is the council's view that this
project does that and is probably the
first such project to have been designed
with these principles in mind
in its posting on the portal i town
council has noted the environmentally
conscious aspects of the design and
considers that this will satisfy the
relevant policies of the i neighborhood
plan
i would like to address the issue of
parking
as this was a significant factor in
resident objections placed on the portal
and my first comment is that a public
engagement strategy for projects like
these might have prevented exaggerated
and in the council's view under
researched impacts of parking demand
taking hold
especially when a building like this is
designed to reduce car use
there's no doubt
eye needs a parking review as it does
with through movement of hgvs
this is why the i neighborhood players
included better management of parking as
a community aspiration
both by better management of the space
we have
and of provision of new car parking as
mentioned in the discussion as a
medium-term objective
we'll work with mid-suffolk officers to
achieve this
and have already formed a parking group
to collect evidence which is already
finding areas for improvement which
could alleviate
any impact on parking demand from this
project
the town council's position as it would
certainly be wrong to stop sustainable
community projects because i needs a
parking review
it's surely better to solve this by
addressing community aspiration one of
the iron neighborhood plan now
i could stagnate if improvements are
delayed because parking is not addressed
back to the development itself
this development is innovative and would
be the first of its kind in eye
innovation is not without risk
but the potential returns in terms of
high quality employment and local
business development are attractive
i town council will work with officers
to seek success for this building
and in tandem to address legitimate
concerns about parking in ai
i hope you will feel able to support
this scheme combined with parallel
efforts to improve parking
so as to begin the environmentally
sustainable future for our town to the
benefit of all its citizens thank you
jeff
thank you very much um
a few questions could you just clear up
the double yellow line question
i'm not sure chair if i'm exactly the
right person to that i think the person
the the company that designed it are
probably better um but there are double
yellow lines uh that go right around the
car parking area which is currently used
in a rather haphazard way i i believe
the design solution actually improves
that and gives us two parking spaces
with electronic parking points and that
would be an improvement
thank you
any other questions for the
town council okay thank you very much
now move on to the applicant we have
kate parnum and kevin white i don't know
who wants to speak but over to you and
again if you can keep to three minutes
please
thank you chair
i'm kevin white from barefoot and gillis
architects architects for the scheme
um as it's been mentioned we're seeking
to contribute to the urgently needed
decarbonization of the council's
building stock and we're looking to do
that with this design
regarding parking the design of the
proposed development has ensured that
the full amount of the available site
area has been used for vehicle parking
this allows two car bays four bike bays
one hundred percent of the bar car bays
have uh electrical charging facilities
and 50 of the bike bays so electric
bikes as well as electric cars
um
in response to representations received
the applicant has also offered to
enlarge the car bays to the disabled
parking site standard as far as possible
within the red line constraints of the
site ownership
so the parking provision overall is as
generous as it can be considering the
existing ownership
regarding disability access the design
does include ramps to both entrances so
there are level accesses to both of the
main entrances to the building
um it will also include or be ensured
through building control approval
process that the doors are wide enough
we can get the turnings into the meeting
room that
there is a full accessibility on that
ground floor
for uh for wheelchair users
regarding photovoltaics it's around
about four kilowatts peak capacity which
should give us something like 7 200
kilowatt hours a year
um the design of the panels includes a
bespoke edging strip which will be will
work with the planning condition
to tie the panels visually into the
existing roof and elevations to prevent
the appearance of a stuck-on
bright shiny set of panels on the roof
just to outline the sustainability
improvements
so we're looking to reduce energy demand
from space heating and cooling by
insulating roof external walls and the
ground floor
adding external solar shading to prevent
overheating which is a key issue with
offices that's on the south windows and
improving natural ventilation
will reduce energy demand from lighting
and small power with high efficiency
leds throughout and installing a rated
appliances
and finally that reduced demand is
supplied by renewables
basically the photovoltaic array on the
south facing roof slope plus the air
source heat pump as noted by the
planning officer located in the external
space to the rear
so this will reduce pollution caused by
the use of the building reducing carbon
emissions and therefore reducing
environmental impact from the beneficial
use of this building
thank you very much
okay any questions at all yeah counselor
even
chair thank you for that um
just on the um
outside area that's within the red line
um there's nothing on our
plans that we've got here
differentiating that from the rest of
the space
um
so how
firstly will it be differentiated will
there be there's sort of a wavy red line
around the parking spaces but i'm not
sure that that actually
represents anything there's no key but
um
will that be um differentiated in any
way um
from
the the rest of the road um and
presumably we've answered the question
that the double yellow lines will
disappear
and
secondly with the um
both those disabled parking spaces
presumably they can be used by anybody
so um
if someone is visiting the pub they
would park there as well thank you
um regarding the double yellow lines um
initial discussions with highways
suggest that it isn't going to be a
problem to amend the um
the road marking layout there
and there's no objection from them in in
us having parking in in that in that
location
regarding the demarcation of the
boundary line the ownership line i'm
assuming is is the the
area requesting
uh asking about i mean it's possible for
brass studs or something to be put in
the ground but it's it's
i don't know currently that's not shown
on the drawings but could be added if
that was a requirement
also madison
thank you yes um
apologies just maybe ought to have gone
to the to the planning office about i've
just found it and um it's it's
absolutely follows on on where we are
discussing at the moment ask questioning
at the moment and and that is the slide
seven
um
should perhaps show a blue line boundary
of ownership as well
um i'm not entirely clear what how it
pans out between
various authorities and so on but i
think it would be valid and useful to
know where where the blue line might go
[Music]
alex jones coming
in terms of the blue line so other land
which is within the suffolk district
council control or ownership yes um
i don't believe we have that as part of
the application um
it could be useful um but uh i don't
believe we have that um
uh
the applicants got their hand up yeah do
you want to come in
um the red line actually is the blue
line as well for us
um
so so the red line is the it's both it's
a red and blue line it's the same line
that is correct yes and the bit outside
next the pub is in county ownership and
they're talking about having an
agreement with the pub around their
access there
okay
any other questions yes cancer field
thank you for the data on the uh
disability issues um
i didn't quite catch the figure you
quoted for the kilowatt hours of the
solar panels could you repeat that
um so the
the rating of the array we would expect
to be around four kilowatt peak it will
depend on the exact specification of the
solar panels but we're expecting around
7 200 kilo hours per year as the output
from the panels thank you
thank you what you said could i could i
just say for 36 panels that's extremely
low
we'll make it easier we'll make it as
high as we can
apologies
they're usually 240 watts each if not
320 and
last time i did maths that comes to a
lot more than four
um
i didn't want to over promise and we
haven't had that engineered as yet
thank you
casa woodward
yes
again it comes back to this carpet
essentially
are these calf parking spaces
uh private car parking spaces for the
use of the office and the bicycle racks
and
the charging points
that's intention yes that's intentional
so they would be
securable i presume from the random use
of the
pub
space by the pub
that would be ideal
but the position that it is in
it's not
not practical to to fence or or you know
physic i mean we could put bollards in
potentially i suppose lockable bollards
but um
at the minutes those aren't shown in the
design
you thank you thank you
okay
uh right so we'll move on uh we now move
on to the ward member uh councillor
girl over to you
thank you very much uh chair and uh
really
all i want to do is um
well first to thank uh town council
richard berry for uh for very clear uh
statements about from the eye
perspective uh and perhaps i just uh add
add a few points uh to to that
um
first in terms of the
the
the planning issues uh which i think
are are very simple uh
in in in this case this is not a change
of use but uh bringing back into use uh
of a derelict office building
uh and to be welcomed for that i think
the description i did when when the uh
report was first published uh have some
calls about
it being titled parish meeting room uh
now i think this is done and that the
case officer may almost payment g may
clarify this but i think this is a
a necessary thing to allow for
uh the town council to meet with members
of the public anything it's not a
full description or or even a main
description of the of the building's use
the uh the proposal as has been said con
provides two parking spaces with uh ev
charging plus four bike spaces two of
which are uh for uh evs uh this is the
same as the previous provision
when the building was in use
now the county council's guidance
suggests four parking spaces so the
actual shortfall here everywhere to
regard it is that as such is is two
spaces i've come to say a little more
about parking uh
in a moment or two
um
one of the big issues in in i is the
need for investment
now the i
neighborhood plan which council berries
referred
provides for over 700
new homes over the life
of the plan which takes up to 2036.
members may well
be aware that uh the neighborhood plan
our neighborhood plan went through
referendum um in may
uh when uh
it an 88 percent uh got 88
support on a very substantial uh turnout
because it was the same day as the
county uh election and indeed the police
commissioner
election
and
they could be say that uh that there's a
a social contract in place with local
people
uh whereby the growth um
is of a type and in a place that they
want to see
so this is the basis of the acceptance
or or indeed
interest in having growth of this scale
it's in a place that they want to see
it's of the type they want to see and
crucially that it's supported by a
proper investment
in supporting infrastructure
and that infrastructure has to include
provision for economic growth growth
because people need jobs as well as
homes
this this initiative
will support help support that need and
aspiration
now
i should to move to parking i has a
parking challenge that parking challenge
does not arise because of this proposal
it is a pre-existing and growing
challenge
as and it's of itself no
no need uh it it makes no uh reason
provides no reason to deny i the
opportunity for this uh this investment
as a community
representative on the investing i board
put it uh this application is
effectively acted as a lightning rod for
uh the pre-existing uh issue and concern
around uh
now council barry referred to the
parking uh
work provision within the
within the neighborhood plan
and there was work that
started on that in particular survey
work uh when covid uh hit
but that work is now being picked up
again uh we have uh a local working
party town working party now in place
which comprises uh yes town council
membership but crucially good community
represented uh representation uh and
business represent representation of
that so if you go to why these days you
may well see people in hi-vis jackets
with clipboards
they are undertaking uh detailed surveys
of parking or parking use and
interestingly one of the early uh
findings that they they
they've come across
is that we don't make very good use of
the parking space that we have
and that actually
our immediate thought and concern was a
was a rush to try and find additional
parking spaces and that work is in hand
but the the early view of the certainly
of the chair of the working group is
that through some management measures uh
we there is no immediate immediate need
for that uh additional uh additional
parking
uh
now um
just to move on to on indeed finish with
with the points and points about
sustainability
now i'm very pleased and proud that i
town cancer
in step with
this council and indeed the county
council
has committed itself
to an ambition in terms of carbon
reduction
as to be a a carbon uh low carbon a
carbon free town
uh
and the could this this building uh
does uh take us some way
helps us along that that journey
um what we've also talked about in the
invest in our board is the idea of
having some exemplar buildings within
the town that can
demonstrate what is possible to achieve
in terms of carbon reduction and this
would be the first could be the first of
those exemplar buildings
the just want to
finish my nature by picking up counselor
eben's question about affordable homes
one of the
factors that got us to
over 700
homes within i was a housing survey
housing need work uh to calculate to
understand the level of affordable homes
likely to be needed in the town and
applying this council's policy uh
and and also looking at sites available
uh
that that's it you know that number of
additional homes will make good
provision uh
for affordable meeting the affordable
need in the town uh in in the future
uh chair i'll finish there um i
commend this this application uh to the
committee thank you thank you very much
any questions for the ward member yeah
councilman
yeah
obviously the
parking has been an overwhelming issue
that's been raised in representations uh
what i'm looking at very very
specifically is is that the the town
council's representative um spoke in
terms of of parallel improvements
um when mentioning parking specifically
and um
and and
the
um you know in the same way you said
there's a social contract with the
residents that uh
you know the problems will be solved and
i noticed that the um the issue of
parking is is apparently actually
number one in the neighborhood plans
list of um
things that things that need to get
sorted so
would it be would it be unreasonable if
if the district council as the owner of
this property um accepting that possibly
in planning terms one one um one could
not be reasonably uh objecting and
refusing um that as an owner we should
ensure that the
the parking
improvements
do actually move in parallel such that
by the time this building comes back
into use
there is actually additional parking
identified and available at that same
moment
thank you very much uh uh
cat smithson i think point is is it is
well made
and certainly there is a determination
clear determination to uh improve
parking provision in in the town this
means net additional space and it means
better management
of of what we have
and certainly i would be very hopeful
indeed that by the time this scheme uh
is is built um
uh and in play
that
additional parking capacity
or freed up parking capacity through
better management measures uh has been
has been achieved
thank you very much
council of war boys
thank you chia um
you have to try and refresh my memory
but how many other ev charging points
are there in eye
two two others two others there and
they're in the large car park community
yeah so so what you have here is is um
this building
uh the new library
uh the newly refurbished uh and admired
public toilets and then the end the end
of that are the two ev
charging charging points which i have to
say are being increasingly uh well used
could you just confirm how many other
parking places there are in the car park
next door
approximately
50 100
various numbers um
being spoken to me so i think safely 50
50 55 places plus or minus
five to ten places so in the range of 50
odd places in the car park next door
thank you very much
well members that's all the information
put before us it's over us now to
discuss debate and come to a conclusion
yeah counselor pass more first off
thank you very much chairman thank you
very much for all the substantive
comments and explanations and questions
so i think we've had a very good debate
here and i have to say that um i think
this is a very good application i do
know the town very well having lived
nearby for nearly 40 years believe it or
not and i can remember when this
particular office was part of the old
csd partnership going back in the midst
of time
but on a more serious point i think the
idea of bringing employment jobs we all
need that is really really important
particularly giving opportunities as i
say many times to the younger generation
that is absolutely fundamental to what
this council should be about
it is in a sensitive location we would
agree with with that and the last thing
that we need in our in my opinion or
anywhere else for that matter
is a building that is vacant becoming
derelict untidy and an unholy mess it
does not do any good at all to do this i
think it's an excellent scheme looking
at what's being used it's sustainable it
has a support not just of the ward
member but the town council
and i think it's very very important i
do believe that the disability questions
have been addressed already
and i think when it comes to the parking
issue
i am absolutely confident that will be
resolved through the parking group and i
think we should leave that up to local
people to decide that and i think
listening to what people have said
i would be very confident that any
issues would be resolved through better
management there are other fairly major
car parks in
walking distance near the town centre
and i know there are pockets of land in
the vicinity that perhaps could be used
better so i would like to propose um
acceptance and move to grant planning
permission for this and i think frankly
just about all the issues that might
have been um talked about have actually
been been addressed chairman so that's
my proposal uh i think we should be on
permission thank you thank you very much
do i have anyone else customer
thanks um i'm very happy
to second that proposal but i would like
to make one comment
the disabled parking spaces as they are
at the moment
i personally think are a hazard
if i drive in
forward into one of those spaces
i cannot leave going forward because of
the bike shed i therefore have to back
out
i won't see down the public entrance to
the car park until my vehicle is
sticking out
into that exit and i think will be
accidents
i i believe they should be configured 90
degrees so that at least you're backing
in and out into a wider space
suffolk county council highways don't
see that as an issue so i don't think
i can disagree with them
but i personally do see that as an
excellent black spot waiting to happen
but otherwise it's it's i think an
excellent scheme and i'm happy to
thanks very much council
thank you chair i just um think if
members are minded to approve this i
wonder if on the conditions
um we can firstly make sure that the
spec for the solar panels takes heritage
issues into consideration
um and secondly
there are ramps on the disabled ramps on
the drawings but can we make sure that
the specification of that for those
covers the appropriate handrails and so
on um
not just
a
ramp itself
and thirdly um
is it possible to kind of put some kind
of informative as it were with regards
to the internal layout in order that
that meets um
disability standards as much as possible
thank you chair
so basically you want you just want i
mean i don't think it i think it could
just be the recommendation that that we
make sure that the site meets all
disability legislation
and which i'm sure it would anyway and
then secondly that the solar panels are
agreed in discussion with officers
are you happy with that
yeah with our with our with our off
officers are you happy with that council
plasma
yeah
yeah okay
well that's why i was just saying we
said we couldn't talk about internal
design but as long as it meets
disability
mag um ultimately um this is a public
building so there's already obligations
in respect of
it would have public access so therefore
you have to comply with the disability
act anyway um
there's no harm putting an informative
note to that effect on the planning
application
uh the i'm
in terms of the specification the solar
panels obviously it's already
conditioned so this the details and
specification would come back to
officers and as heritage is part of our
department we're part of the same team
so that's not a problem in any event
i'm a little confused about these ramps
i'm i'm i think if we just agree for a
full dis that that we make sure we meet
all disability
requirements because then that's all we
can do we can't condition things that
are outside
the point there is that they've
obviously decided to look at the
looking at the area looking at the
photos of the site
it already seems to be a level access
anyway but um
my comment would be that a condition to
say effectively for the avoidance of
doubt you're looking at level access for
disabled access
to be agreed
thank you
okay anyone else wish to speak before we
go to a vote uh council matheson yeah i
think i think on the the disability
issues is perhaps slightly um
poorly
expressed in the representation and the
perhaps the the point is the posts
not the
the slope or non-slope um it might be
level but it may be that the the poster
i'm sorry to interrupt but i don't think
we should be saying what should or
shouldn't be there we should just make
sure it meets the guidance we're not
experts in the requirements of
disability
access
so
if we condition that we make so what
wording can we use to make sure that we
meet all the requirements of the
disability
particularly the disability forum and
their concerns
we just make as says it's compliant with
the
dda i don't think we need to complicate
it anymore because that should take a
take account of that otherwise it
wouldn't be compliant
okay so that's conditioned thank you
yeah
yeah i think i think the other point
really and if it may be that one of uh
that this needs to be dealt with through
one of mr isabel's famous informatives
um really is in terms of our
responsibilities as the the owner and
the applicant
um and you know there's two things that
seem to be
troubling still really one is is we have
policy to keep the pubs open or at least
one per per settlement and and this is
this is the only one in in i as far as i
know and and it has had its problems
already so i think you know that is a
worry
that we
we should not
do something with the parking
arrangements in front of our property
which is actually going to seriously
impede them that is a concern the other
concern that i don't think we should
brush aside too quickly really is the
effect of the parking problems on all
the other businesses you know we have an
economic development responsibility and
we're we've we're trying to fulfill that
which is great here and yes we want to
see the building opened again
but we don't want it to be at the
expense of making life even more
difficult for all the existing
businesses so you know i'd really like
us to be setting that out very clearly i
mean we've heard counselor goulds is
hopeful that the two things
might be delivered at the same time
um but i think that for me
i'd want us to really set that out with
the permission
can i just say that i mean i'll just
give my i haven't expressed a view yet
so i think this is this is an existing
office
we're bringing an existing office a new
better use of an asset
where we ask for environmental
conditions to be thought through and
clearly they have
um we want people actually to cycle
their john not go by car
you always you know that's one of your
strong things you would rather people
cycled so actually i'm happy that we see
people cycle there or walk there
rather than always driving and also i
has a very good bus service so i'm
hopeful people can get in through other
means of transport so for me i don't i
don't think it needs more i'm happy with
what council passed more and may have
put forward and i'll be supporting that
uh cancer war boys
uh thank you chairman i
i agree as much as what has been said i
is a growing community
uh i think this is a really interesting
development it's it's bringing back a
redundant building as you say and making
uh
it available to to the public for use as
office space it's a diversification of
the use
of the um
of the spaces in the town
um
i think
the car parking and bike storage system
it's not
it's not enough for the
if the office space is full i don't
think
this is a subjective opportunity but i
don't think there's enough car parking
space or bicycle space for
everybody who will you'd be using that
building if the building is at full
capacity just counting the number of
chairs
um i think there's a we are we are kind
of designing in a sort of point of
conflict between
the use of the
space outside the queen's 8 for
deliveries and occasional parking
picking people up it's a congested area
um there is
a large car park a short walk away there
are more disabled spaces and two more
ev charging points
i think managing
this as a private ev
charging point
and bicycle storage system for the sole
use
of the office block is
i don't think it's going to be
manageable
because people use it
if they're visiting the pub with a bike
and that's the only secure
bicycle storage rack that i know of you
know you can
correct me
they will put their bike there
um
so
that that is i think my my whether that
could be conditional whether that could
be made accessible to the public
it's a disabled parking space again
disabled people it's closer than the
existing public
disabled spaces and
though it's the district council
officers
it's owned by the district council and
they have a public responsibility to not
just have a private car parking space
very close to a public community
does i think i've explained my point but
okay thank you you asked me to clarify
anyone else wish to come in before we go
to a vote
yup casterfield
you know so some risk i'm just going to
say what council warbler has said again
in different words
uh obviously environmental benefits as
the conversion to this building seems
significant and bringing it back into
use is also significant
i do find this um
the ratio of the number of desks was
around 20 to the available car park in a
worry
clearly we'd all like everybody to cycle
or walk to to work and and situated in
the middle of the town there is a
possibility that that will occur
uh but there is a vague feeling that we
are building a problem
and certainly a problem for the uh for
the adjacent pub which is a business we
want to survive
i guess on balance i've got to the point
that i uh go along with it if it's um
parking is a real god awful problem then
this conversion won't be viable
and that's down to
us who chooses to finance it and so
not really as us as a planning authority
to um
to to try and solve the unsolvable there
isn't a
space for additional parking here and
we've all heard about the
um
the scheme to revise parking across eye
which again may or may not achieve a big
difference
so i think with some reluctance i'm
inclined to go along with this
that's the past we want to come back
before we go yep now thank you thank you
i was just going to say i'm picking up
on john's point here regarding the
inferring the working group i mean i
really would be quite confident they
will come up with solutions i absolutely
understand everybody's concerns i think
they're very well made points but
i'm sure they would have listened to
what has been said here and i don't
think we can actually condition it but
certainly some sort of advisory note
more than happy with that just to say
please have a look at this very
carefully find out how you can make it
even more sustainable than it is and i'm
sure that would deal with it because i
know there's a real willingness of
people locally to to address this so it
does not become a problem it doesn't
make it um the whole project on viable
thank you cancer burn
thank you chairman um i'm not going to
repeat any of what's been said
previously
i think it's been aired extremely well
i shall be supporting this uh
i'm i'm very pleased to see something
like this come forwards
mainly because
or particularly because it
brings the town council
and the clerk
uh into much
closer contact with the community it
makes them immediately available
um and i think that for a town like i
can can only be a good thing the
the present
meeting facilities in the town hall
are not really suitable for um informal
uh conversation with the councillors or
um
or the clerk i think this makes it uh
a very much a step in in in
resolving that problem um so i shall be
supporting okay thank you very much
councilman you want to come out yeah
yeah um it sounded as if council passed
more was was um was rising to my uh
suggestion of an informative i wonder
whether council and mayor might join in
and we could actually get to
that an informative council did
so what would the informative note
actually say because i'm not clear
turns regarding the part
do you want to come in i'm not sure
that's an informative at all but
okay
let's forget the
involvement of the council as district
council at the moment we're the local
planning authority we deal with
anyone as in the applicant
and we have to deal with them in terms
of planning bulls
would it be this is a note so
in many respects it's literally the
applicant just can read it and ignore it
entirely there's nothing we can do about
that this is not a condition
but ultimately um
what does he actually ask them to do
in terms of
any kind of actions with that a
reasonable necessary or
you know
another respect yeah the chairman you
could argue any advisory note is not
really worth the salt the paper it's
written on but i'm just trying to be
helpful here to address concerns that
members have made in order to
come up with a solution i mean it's
pretty obvious it's common sense i know
you can't have common sense when it
comes to planning conditions but
actually
um but actually without being flippant
seriously um something like that just to
put in an appendix i do think would help
address it and there have been some
local people so can we actually
i'm really sorry but we're going around
around in circles
of what the information is
i think it sounds as though an
informative is to ensure that the
parking um for this application
considers the accessibility to the pub
and the um proposed parking um reforms
within i
so that they're just looking at
looking at those and just so we've got
the concerns about access to the pub and
concerns about that lots of people have
raised i mean i'd rather even walk there
but
we've got to
listen to the community's views and the
communities have said they've got a
concern about this so if we can just say
the informative says we shall
review the
consider in the parking
condition that
the access to the pub and the um
forthcoming
review of parking in i
is that possible i can make a suggestion
um i'm writing down a note to request
that the final parking arrangement to be
agreed as your condition that is in your
recommendation takes into account
the public house and the what was the
other the advisory
are you happy with that
yep okay we're there
i think uh
we will on that basis just to ask
uh
just to run through the recommendations
obviously on page 25 of the papers as
laid out
with the additional
informative
and then the additional bullet points
about the disability
meeting disability
what is the exact wording of that alex
can you come in or john and then we'll
go to the vote
so the recommendation before members at
the moment
and forgive me because i've lost the
page
right so the recommendation
is uh for us to be authorized to grant
planning permission uh subject to the
conditions on page
which is a standard time limit approved
plans
notwithstanding the submitted
information parking layout to be agreed
uh proposed sustainable millages that
propose sustainability measures to be
fully uh implemented prior to first use
occupation
details of the solar panels to be agreed
the render color to be agreed and the
biodiversity enhancements to be fully
implemented that have been proposed as
well and in addition to that
if i go back to my other notes we are
looking to add a condition
to for the avoidance of doubt that level
access for disabled use details shall be
agreed including any handrails
and carried out
we have an informative note on disable
access and internal arrangements to be
compliant
a informal note to request the final car
parking to be agreed as per condition
takes into account the public house and
forthcoming parking review
and
finally i'm going to confirm that the
details for the solar panels condition
shall be considered by both planning and
heritage officers
okay thank you on that basis we'll go to
the vote please
it's just being typed up in one second
thank you members
that vote is now in progress
in your app
uh
i think we're okay
thank you chair that's seven votes four
and one against
you
councillor byrne i'm sorry we are
starting
yes castlefield
just made clear on this one i i
obviously they're talking about lobbying
being involved as the
previous now county councillor
for this area i've been involved in many
discussions at the parish
over god knows how many years involving
this particular
application i don't think that
represents
a serious issue that um i should really
wait for non-pecuniary interest
thank you
okay so we're going to move straight
into uh
dc2103087 the cross keys in henley
and now hand over to the case officer
alex scott and she's the item and just
for the record councillor password is
the ward member for this so won't be
voting and we'll get an opportunity to
speak later thank you
okay thank you chairman um members of is
item 7b in the papers application
reference dc 2103087
um site at the cross keys public house
at bell's cross
near henley
the application before you is
proposing an extension and
use of part of the existing pub and
outbuilding
for two holiday let's
the erection of ancillary cycle store
stroke dog shower building
a covered barbecue area recycling area
solar pv array and ev charging points
all proposals would be ancillary to the
existing public
house land use so we'll move forward to
the presentation
so the location of henley within the
district the avoidance of dact
the location of the site
[Music]
within the immediate area at the bells
cross crossroads to the north of henley
um an aerial view of the wider site
and
the site location aerial view
uh this is a constraints map um so very
few constraints other than it's
in open countryside uh no settlement
boundary around uh
around bells cross itself um there are a
few uh listed buildings in the vicinity
and uh we have bullies for wood which is
ancient woodland so they're the main
constraints
this is a site location plan
of the site so the application site
outlined in red and further site to the
south which is uh described
in this and other applications as the
orchard
which is also ancillary
um now this is the proposed site layout
showing the proposals so we have
the existing outbuilding here proposed
to be extended and converted to one
holiday let
the existing garage an existing store
here and extension proposed to be
another holiday let
the remainder of the pub would remain uh
for that use and that would be continue
to be the principal land use of the site
and building
uh we have a little bit of the uh
existing beer garden uh given over to um
external community space for the car
lodge holiday let's however
a large area of beer garden would remain
this is the area of the cycle store and
dog shower the covered barbecue area
recycling area the solar pv array and
the additional parking for the electric
uh vehicle charging there
um existing elevations of the building
and proposed that sorry existing floor
plans of the public house building
proposed elevations so the extension
would be
in this
this area here
just
sitting in nicely there
and the proposed floor plans and um as
you can see the existing bar
and um
dining areas uh the bar servery the
kitchen and
once them the cellar would remain as
well as upstairs
ancillary living and storage space
this is the area proposed to be given
over to one of the holiday let's and
this is the extension at back
and we have an area of the existing
store and garage which will be uh
supposed to be converted as part of the
application
this is the existing act building which
as you saw on the layout sits behind the
existing pub building
so that's proposed to be extended uh
with a living room extension extending
away from the uh existing public house
building and converted to another
holiday left
and these are the uh elevations of the
ancillary structures the uh the bike
bike store secure bike parking a a dog
shower for washing down dogs after
walking uh presumably the uh
covered barbecue station
and a section of the solar pv
uh array
uh onto some photographs uh the existing
frontage of the building and uh access
and then looking towards the crossroads
along the frontage this is a view from
the car park
looking towards the rear of the building
you might be able to see the cart lodge
to the rear there
into the existing beer garden and
cart lodge and that would be extended
that way the proposed extension beyond
that
and then from the uh street scenes our
existing garage proposed to be converted
you can see the cart lodge adjacent to
the highway in that direction
and then just a closer view of the areas
of conversion and extension from that
adjacent highway
so that concludes the presentation
as in your papers officer recommendation
of approval with conditions thank you
chairman
thank you
um any questions the case officer at
this time yeah councilman and cancer
can you confirm the publish currently
closed
um it certainly appears that way from my
site visit yes
that's reuben
um thank you chad i just wondered why
we've um
it's the um
sorry the conditions talk about three
not exceeding three holiday let's on the
site but we only have got two um and my
um
and therefore if the could the pub then
decide not to run and turn the pub into
a
the third one so um or have the third
one as the whole building for example so
could you just explain why it's three
and
um not two thinking
um i believe that may be a uh mistake or
the eric planning manager might have
more information
can we just go back to the plans then
because there are three proposed you've
got part of the pub which is becoming a
holiday let and you've got two
outbuildings that are becoming holiday
alerts
you need to go back to the plan so
clarify this
or is there any two so we mate said
three by mistake and we should have only
put two
yeah my question was because there's
yes so
one one out building one last one and
then the extension to the part but i can
my concern was if
that's two that's it isn't it
oh okay so uh apologies then uh in terms
of the recommendation
where it says shall not exceed free we
should actually be putting not exceed
two
uh can we yeah so please accept that as
our correction and apologies and the
other reason to actually put that
condition on there is so that
subdivision of the two
to make them three four five whatever
can't occur it has to be
two total
so it's two thank you
if i can come back chair the the
concern is that if the pub's currently
closed and hasn't got an active license
the
can the pup at a later date
say we want to be
a holiday let
and we want to rent out the building as
a you know large four bed holiday letter
whatever but that would be the subject
of a further application to be decided
at a later date and you'll also see that
in our conditions we've actually said
that for the essentially this applies to
the holiday let
that's part of the pub that it can't be
expanded so you can't just make it
bigger and bigger and bigger
thank you casamayor
two things one are you confident that
the um
the requirement that the
holiday accommodation remain ancillary
to the principal public house land uses
a stronger
influences we can bring on
the pub to reopen and continue in
business
the second point really is is
have highways in any way commented on
the
the redevelopment of the garage area
because uh
visibility at that junction is is pretty
poor in that area so
but i guess the building already exists
so difficult to know what to do but the
question is have highways
proposed any action
um thank you councilmember um no i don't
think um the issue of the loss of the
garage has specifically been raised by
highways however i think the
resultant
onsite turning and parking and provision
would be acceptable there's certainly a
significant uh car park i would suggest
on the site that could be used and
perhaps is being used by current
occupants of the building um certainly
when i was on site it that seemed to be
the case
um the garage as well is
again this hasn't been mentioned by
specifically by highways but i would
suggest it is rather narrow and i would
question whether that meets current
parking standards for garage widths uh
anyway um
if that's helpful
maths
yes i
thought we'd better just get
a clarity around uh caravans i know
that's a wonderfully complicated and uh
uh obscure kind of um area um
do we need to be um
putting some sort of constraint on how
many caravans or how long or or
something i mean we are giving some sort
of um
permission to use the land for
touring caravans um
which i mean seems in principle to be a
good idea if it's a holiday
you know holiday operation then the
camping yes
tour caravans yes
but do we need to just look at that a
little closely
john papendrick
the proposal before you is not campsite
or caravan park that is not part of this
application
that is something that the applicant
might be thinking about to the land to
the south of this public house
but ultimately they feel they can do
that under permitted development given
the number of caravans units they are
proposing so therefore it is not within
our remit to deal with that
okay do you agree with their assumption
that they can do it under permitted
development i think that would help us
quite a lot if you said no or yes
uh it comes down to the number and i
believe it's less than five
thank you
okay
john castlefield do you want to come
back sorry i cut you off early
okay it was just i thought there was a
misunderstanding between us there that
uh what i was asking was that the
the garage of the pub is exceedingly
close to the adjacent road
and i personally have had to deal with
the
questions about a number of serious
accidents there not to do with the car
parking at the gara at the pub at all
but to do with
people
exiting that side road
and it was just questioning whether
highways had
indicated they're satisfied with this
it's not an opportunity to make some
improvement i was just looking for your
comment on
that yes uh thank you councillor phil um
yes but as i mentioned i don't believe
the highways have commented specifically
on the garage but um if it's felt there
is a safety issue um well then that
would be removed as part of this
proposal one could say
can't surpass me
thank you very much chairman um just a
question on page 69 on place services
it's got in the middle there
no objection subject to securing a
proportionate financial contribution
towards visitor management measures for
the star and orwell estuaries
now what is an appropriate
financial contribution i'm baffled as to
why we'll be getting involved with the
river store which is
many miles away from mid-suffolk
and i'm not
don't to my
don't recall ever seeing anything like
that before
and um
it's quite a difficult one proportionate
what are we talking about 50 quid 100
but if we were talking about thousands
that's a complete but i don't know but
it'd be i think we'd i would really be
interested to hear what it is please
thank you chair um i can clarify that
henley lies within the
zone of influence for
the recreational disturbance at the
demon estuary not the storm or well and
therefore it is a
tariff under the adopted suffolk coast
recreational avoidance mitigation
strategy
so
it should save diva necessary
off the top of my head i think it's
about
120 pounds something like that per unit
yes
yes thank you thank you
i'm well spotted
okay
no other questions we'll move on to the
speakers then so um first of all like to
invite uh the parish council uh kevin
griggs
you have
three minutes
thank you councillor hicks um
any paris council we've been trying for
years to support plans which would keep
the cross keys open as a pub
we don't accept to never have the often
repeated argument that the site is
fundamentally doomed and will never make
money the suffolk county side is dotted
with thriving pub restaurants in
unpromising locations
and they work because they are offering
some people and are willing to travel to
the old days of the pub which will only
survive if we've been a walking distance
of committed drinkers have long gone
nowadays the business is about food
families and there's nothing wrong with
the cross keys as a site for the
proposition in its right in the right
hands
the paris council has consistently
opposed the current owners multiple
change of use applications
we will continue to do so
whoever owns it it's a real and
unnecessary shame that the cross keys
are stood empty and unused since 2014
and the paris council will back anyone
who wants to run it as an attractive
venue for food drink and entertainment
when his application was tabled we said
in the light of the history of the site
the paris council requests that any
planning permission includes a clear
condition that as promised by the
applicant the pub is reopened once all
the work and renovation has been
completed and that all reasonable
efforts are made to run it successfully
for the foreseeable future
it's perhaps understandable that the
planners briefing note says that the
condition is not enforceable and it's
true we can't oblige someone to run a
successful business
but we surely we can put real weight
behind the insistence that we are only
supporting the application on the basis
that the application delivers on his
promise to do his very best to make the
place work
we understand that we can't be
a legal obligation but it can certainly
be a moral obligation and surely the
committee could be at least very at
least at least make it very clear
if he if they approve the application
that his support is based on promise to
reopen the pub
no one can guarantee profitability but
the applicant has to stand by his
commitment expressed at the public paris
meeting that he will use all his
expertise
in this field to make the pub work
the complication of course and the
source of the public unease is that the
applicant doesn't act doesn't actually
own the pub as yet
we don't know the terms of the deal
between him and the current owner
it is fair to say that is there is not
much local confidence in the current
owner and it would be amazing if he
didn't still have a long-term eye on the
potential development value of the site
if the pub was to fail
it's reassuring that the planners
recommendations are clear that the
holiday let's must not be operated or
occupied independently and are not to be
occupied
as independent dwellings i will have to
be the last sentence please the times
are i've got but possibly remains this
could be stage one of a process of
development creek unless there is
clearest possibility that the statement
from the committee
that it would not entertain a renewed
future change of use application into
residential development site the paris
council supports the application with
some interpretation and nervousness and
invites the committee to share our hope
that the site will be successful pub
thank you rather than stepping stone to
on what would you be thank you okay um
i'll give the applicant another half a
minute as well just to be to be fair
when we come on to that um so any
questions at all for the parish council
yeah council eben
um
thank you chair it's probably it's more
for the officer really because one of
the things i wanted to check was that
plan that condition which the um
parish councillor has has mentioned
um
it it kind of says holiday that wants
this holiday accommodation to remain
ancillary to principal public house land
use it kind of says you can't have the
holiday let's unless it's a public house
and it goes on saying not to be occupied
or operated independently so they
couldn't be open if the pub's not open
well that's what i just wanted to check
is that actually the case or is that um
so that they
um with all the will in the world there
is nothing we can do to force a pub to
open
so ultimately the use is there that's
the planning matter
um
there is
there is the chance
that the holiday unit can operate with
the pub still closed
there is nothing i can do to avoid that
that is not within the power of that
condition
but it's used but it hasn't it can only
be used well it's got the use
that the public house has got the use of
the public house the fact that it might
not be open as a public houses yes
ultimately if the use of the public
house disappears entirely then
that condition effectively would be in
breach
thank you for that okay uh so we'll move
on got another question so we'll move on
to the applicant mr chris bernard
welcome and uh three and a half minutes
for you as well thank you very much um
if i could just make clear this uh
public house had had previous planning
applications that were nothing to do
with me i wasn't involved with it at
that stage and certainly didn't own it
um
my personal background is is i've bought
a number of failed rural pubs and put
them back together and um
and made them successful businesses
basically and but largely what i've done
is reconfigured a lot of badly
configured space with pubs typically
pubs will have rambling out buildings if
they've been failed pubs they'll have no
investment they'll be run down they'll
be they'll be pretty cocky at that stage
so
what i've tended to do is got a pub back
on its feet and made it successful for
the long term but as part of that i've
usually created additional accommodation
which will either be holiday let rental
or bmp
which help the whole thing work as a
business long term so
this is pretty much as heavy cross keys
it's been closed for 70 years to my
knowledge the previous owner before that
went bankrupt
in my pub experiences in a really poor
position um so it does need ancillary
income to make it work you know it's
it's pieces of a jigsaw
relying on doing a traditional pub in
that location will struggle in my
opinion but if you put some other
elements with it to help additional
income
and uh regard to the caravan aspect it's
not part of the planning application
because with a cl site certified
location you can have up to five touring
caravans um with no planning permission
so that would be another string to the
bow although that's not strictly part of
the planning application because we
don't need it
if we can enhance the whole building the
existing one of the existing holiday
units where the garage was for instance
that's a redundant garage that hasn't
been used for anything park junk so what
we're doing is we're repurposing
redundant space we're not losing any of
the existing trading area the pub we're
just making the best that the space is
either badly configured or not used for
anything at all at the moment um
so that that in line we're trying to
bring up the 21st century solar panels
and air source heat pumps we're trying
to make
a contemporary holiday let's in a
sustainable location that will enhance
the whole community and
enhance the sustainability of that pup
you put all those things together you've
got something that has a potential to
work for a long time um
you know i i i can i can put the fabric
the thing together and i run pubs but
this needs for something to be
successful it needs to be successful for
the long term
and so if you put the framework of that
together i'm hopefully providing
something that will have longevity
and have value for a for an operator
because at the moment
it's not a feasible business for anybody
it's not a reasonable business it fails
as a community facility a pub's only a
good community facility
if someone who owns it can earn
themselves a living basically so if you
get all those elements right together
this can work but we do need these other
elements to keep this bug for the long
term
thank you very much
okay any questions at all
no okay thank you for that uh now move
on to the ward member we have two ward
members uh
um for this site uh council are you
speaking from both i haven't heard from
councilwoman no um john asked me to make
it very clear we've spoken about this
and we had the parish council meeting
last night so i am speaking on behalf of
both thank you um thank you very much
and um
very pleased that this application has
come forward and it has the support of
the parish council it has been a
protracted process for many many years
and although john field was the county
councillor for much longer than i've
been one of the district councillors
this has been an issue that has been
going on you've heard the pub has been
shut for seven years
it's in a remote location from the
center of the village but nevertheless
um being not far outside for vip switch
and with all the housing development
that is going on in the vicinity from
barham to clayden and elsewhere um
i do think it has got considerable
potential but what it does need to do is
to have an offer which is not about
going down there and a few beers and
going off back the fields
ploughing and harvesting and things like
that all in reverse order actually um
but it's well put together i like the
way there is a range of activities that
have been put there it does need to
boost its income if it's to be
successful
it could do the food offer etc etc but
by having the accommodation there i
think it does give it more than a
fighting chance of being successful i
also personally think that having other
attributes such as dog showers barbecues
and some will actually enhance the the
potential visitor offer so i think it's
well put put together and we've
clarified the issue about any
environmental payments for the uh deben
area so i hope we've all got that on
board and um
in my view the hospitality industry at
the moment needs all the help it can get
we are actually quite short of
accommodation like this in the mid
suffolk area
and with the support of the parish
council which i think is critical as i
say it has has huge huge potential on
that
just to reassure people my personal view
is that if someone were trying to do
this as a long-term objective just to
get change of use of residential
development we already have policies in
place to prevent that happening and i
think that's absolutely fundamental
and i think um the the area planning
officer chief area planning officer has
clarified the point about keeping the
pub open and you can't it just expand
extra accommodation in there so chairman
i don't need to repeat anything else
that others have said i think it's a
very good application put together it's
supported by the parish council and i
really do hope um on the sustainable
basis that it will be good for the
economy locally
it will use what is effectively a
redundant building to very good effect
so i if it's successful i certainly wish
the applicant's luck
um and hope the committee is able to
support it thank you thank you very much
any questions for the ward member
no okay so up to us to discuss debate
and come to a conclusion council
matheson first yeah well i i think you
know this is this is tremendously
welcome um i've been past the place i
think i've actually been in it once a
long time ago
and um
you know i think in
you know in approving it as i'm sure we
will
um
we're effectively reaffirming
what was said some um
2017 in fact on page 53 the previous um
refusal
um of of conversion to residential did
did um that committee on that day seem
to have set out there still very very
clearly
and i think the policies
then
are at the moment the policies now
and that the policies that we may have
in the emerging joint local plan will be
even stronger if anything in in making
the same point so
i think it's jolly good and i'll listen
to what one or two people have got to
say but probably we're not going to take
long
councillor ebon's next on cancer field
um thank you very much chair um i too
think this is a positive application and
i'm pleased that the um
consultation with the parish council and
um the community that's
you know there's been clearly been good
discussions on this
my main concern is that
i would want to see the public house
being the public run as a pub and not be
ultimately converted into residential
and i think we need to make that very
very clear that um
that
you know obviously we can't tell what
applications might come forward in the
future but the the point of this
application is to have a a functioning
pub um that is um you know economically
viable and with these um
two holiday
let units then i think that would um
improve that situation you know
and provide also you know visitors to
the area and so on which
would be very beneficial so on that
basis chair i'd be happy to
propose approval of the application
thank you
thank you councilfield
has been said this has been a long
saga of this pub and this seems to be an
opportunity to to
move it on if not bring it totally to a
conclusion
there have been previous attempts to
gain some
additional financial benefit from the
site
and that's absolutely necessary in my
view to support the
viability of the pub itself so to
holiday let's see a good solution
and has been said the the other
facilities that are proposed
seem
also to move in in the right direction
so i i think i'm quite happy to uh
secondly this application
um the approval of this application
uh
one is concerned obviously about the
issue that um we don't really wish to
see um holiday let's build and the pub
fail to reopen um
it does sound as though that's not the
intention of the applicant but but uh
i think we should make it very clear
that that
condition we have that talks about the
holiday that's being
ancillary to the principal public house
land use
will be enforced
if that doesn't happen then the holiday
let's we'll have to cease
um and that's as far as we can go to
guaranteeing the future we all wish to
see
i think that poses so happy second thank
you cast of food did i have another hand
up did anyone else wish to speak on this
note says
did you it's been proposed by council e
burn sector by council field
there is a point that the the money for
the divan estuary um visitor et cetera
et cetera impact um isn't actually in
the recommendation um that presumably
needs to be in there somewhere
uh so in terms of that there's a
different arrangement in respect to that
payment because it comes up virtually
for every um
unit of accommodation within a very
large area the influence area is about
13 kilometers
we have an upfront payment system that
is in place instead and i'm assuming but
i did put a note to check before we
release any decision that that has taken
place that is why it doesn't need to be
secured as a section 106 agreement or
undertaking
but i had noted that and just to double
check before any decision is released so
that would deal with the payment section
and just in terms of the recommendation
going forward just to clarify for the
record obviously we need to change that
condition from three to two uh and
that's been noted thank you thank you
very much i mean this is i mean i can't
i mean the previous applicant the
previous owner of the pub rather has
been to this committee
many times over many years
and actually i you know this is a this
is the first real positive
site we've seen that there's a future
for this pub i drive past that pub every
day i would love to stop in for
something to eat on the way home but you
know it's just never it hasn't so i
really wish you good luck i think the
moral side of it you've heard from
everyone the implications you've heard
from the parish council you know there
is a huge good will behind you so please
just uh i think listen to what the
parish council has said about that fine
balance between the holiday
accommodation and the need for the pub
so we thank you very much we'll go to a
vote then with that bullet point four
changed to two
and it's proposed by council event
sector by council field over to you
thank you chair members that vote has
been amended to um reflect
two rather than three
so
let me just start that should now be
showing in progress
thank you chair that's seven votes for
and councillor passmore is not voting as
ward member
thank you okay thank you very much thank
you okay so what we'll do is we'll start
again at 11 30. so we have a quick 10
minute break
uh
depends which clock you look at but it's
about 10 minutes
folks
um
you
we're just up
there's a slight problem uploading the
technology but it's nearly there
okay so welcome back everyone uh
we're now moving on to the uh next
agenda item which is application 7c
the land at ling road in palgrave um
so we have john payment g who's going to
present this just for a matter of
clarity the ward members council david
byrne on this application who will
obviously not be able to vote so tron
over to you
thank you
so this is for the use of land for the
sighting of four off-grid holiday units
and erection of a replacement store
strike housekeeping building
with also the installation of pvp panels
upgrading of an existing access and
track and new
low level impact parking and foul
drainage and this is at ling road at
palgrave
and i've got to remember how to use this
thing so if i hit that one that's right
um so starting wide uh this is
essentially uh the ling valley um
woven ling is just indicated uh close to
where the site is
there's a car park quite close by as
well the site is actually just here
so if we go
a bit further in
that's the site on the top left
and i've just put in a different aerial
view uh because i thought it was
important we've got the older one which
is on our records that we're allowed to
use but the google
map on the bottom right is
only a few couple of years old
potentially so it's more recent than the
one on the top left but just to give you
a comparison it also comes sometimes
comes across different seasons so
that is the
obviously highly landscaped significant
landscape and countryside
location
for clarity this is the site location
plan shows me the red area which is for
the the change of use
site area and all of the land is
indicated that was in the ownership of
the site is in the blue areas as shown
and the access
at the moment is just there and it will
be upgraded as part of this proposal
come to that in a moment there's a
constraint
so the site is
within the
special landscape area which is the
subject of the designation of your
policy cl2 of the local plan 98
essentially that
designation says that within special
landscape areas particular care will be
taken to safeguard landscape quality and
where development does occur it should
be sensitively designed with high layer
high standards of layout materials and
landscaping
but this policy does not prevent
prevent development in principle in
itself
the site is also uh partly within uh
flood zone two three uh which is this
little bit coming out here and you'll
see that on later plans as well
this extract is to show that the
um
site
if i just find where the site is bear
with me
so the site is just in here
what we have
adjacent to the site
is the triple s eye
of the ling
and we also have royden fenn
uh wildlife site
just to the north as well
so you can see the fairly significant
designations
there
if i go into
this
a little bit more this is the site
layout i've come back to that in a
moment we have a small
wooded area here that isn't in the
triple si but essentially the triple si
meets the boundary of the site just here
so it is regarded as adjacent
so we have the proposal for four units
spread across the site
um with a managed fire pit to the middle
to the fire pit
is indicated as there
you can see the overlay of the flood
zone has been pushed into the site there
and we have one two
three
and four units
um the existing outbuilding that's on
the side of the moment is just in here
that was to be replaced with a new
store an ancillary building
and we have the existing parking so
existing access
would drive coming through to parking
area in here
this is uh elevations of the
accommodation proposed
it is on stilts although they are small
and ultimately it's a slightly
contemporary design but modest and using
natural materials
this is the replacement accommodation
outbuilding
for store and housekeeping
and we also have the entrance uh being
upgraded to a standard highways
requirement of
visibility uh for 90 meters in both
directions
some photos just to give you an idea so
just looking into the sides that's the
current building on the left hand side
as you come in
and essentially you that you drive in
through oh my mouse you drive through
and into the side and the various units
of accommodation would be spread out
within the site itself
that's the existing access
and these are views either way along the
current road
and opposite
black i'll leave it on there
so the current local plan and nppf do
not seek to oppose tourism uses in the
countryside but it is important to
consider
all of the planning merits and all
material considerations
the site is extremely well screened from
public views
more screening and significant
landscaping is proposed
the built forms are modest in scale
and have you know fairly
a soft pallet of materials proposed and
dispersed across the site
there is no objection in terms of
residential amenity or highway safety
grounds
economic impacts will be limited
and there will be significant
biodiversity enhancements
the recommendation includes securing the
enhancements and management matters to
secure the site as it is proposed in a
sensitive location
um one update to make since the writing
of the report on the 2nd of september
after the report was
submitted we received a further letter
from suffolk wildlife trust
um this was meant to be included in the
table papers but i don't believe it got
there we've got two supporting letters
but not this letter
and i apologize for that
so i've got to address this verbally
instead uh in summary um the suffolk
wildlife trusts have revised their
position to a holding objection
now there's two points behind this
holding objection the first is that the
there is insufficient information on the
borehole and associated solar pump
now this is a complicated matter because
it's not very often the planning gets
involved in boreholes
and we also have the backup that the
environment agency would have to give a
licence for that in any event we don't
have an objection from the
environment agency on in this case
however there is no reason why we cannot
impose a further condition to seek the
details of the borehole
for agreement and if we don't feel that
it is
agreeable then we don't have to take
that any further so i would recommend to
members that we have a further condition
to seek details of the borehole
given the objection of the suffolk
wildlife trust
the second part of their holding
objection
is they
continue to feel that the site lies
directly adjacent to the uh river
waverly
um
and essentially if i can sum it up
sufficiently
feel that the proposal have the
potential to cause the fragmentation of
the habitats within the area and
therefore cause damage to wildlife
corridor in what is an undeveloped
stretch of the river
so that one is their viewpoint and
it is a viewpoint that is not agreed uh
given the ecologist consultation
responses that we have had as part of
the application
so i will leave that at that point
but our recommendation so i go back to
that is one of approval
subject to the conditions laid out in
your papers on page 109
thank you
thanks very much okay questions yes
councilman
yeah the um
at the beginning you you use the um
innocuous words upgrade the access
um and there's been unfortunate
experiences
bearing in mind it's a 60 mile an hour
national
limit there um that upgraded accesses
involve a huge amount of hedge loss
um i wonder whether we can um be
reassured
as to um
how much will be lost
can i just put the thing back on again
uh if i just hit to the right a slide
bear with me
in fairness as you can see there is a
degree of highway embankment in any
event uh before you hit any kind of
trees or hedges that are set back
we're looking left and then right um
ultimately if i then go to the highway
visibility plan
which isn't that way around sorry one
way go the other way
so we got 2.4 meters back you then have
90 meter visibility in each direction uh
in one direction that's not going to do
anything to the boundary treatment of
the
the site because of the the way the road
curves in the other direction uh the
left there you will see that i would
imagine that's going to need a little
bit of cut back of the hedgerow that's
there
but it's not intention to remove any
trees or remove the hedgerow so
i can't say for certain here but i would
abso
it appears to be limited given the the
way the road curves to seek that to be
cut back
greatly
but it is
needed as
in terms of ensuring you say it's a 60
mile now road to get the visibility to
ensure highway safety that is a
requirement and the other requirement
would be also to have
the surface material on the access
apron as well to ensure that you don't
have things rolling off the the driving
and other standard requirements
okay thank you any other questions yes
cassie burn the cats in there
thank you very much chair um i've got
three questions if i may firstly the
um access driveway and the parking hard
standing do we know what that is
made of is it
um
is it permeable
surface or
or not
secondly the um
the sla
and triple si
are there any
protections for the for these land
special landscape areas in the emerging
joint local plan
and thirdly the nppf has quite a lot to
say about development in these areas and
i just don't get a full enough sense of
the mpps requirements so could you help
me out there thank you very much
so in terms of the the the driveway and
parking uh surface
so they would be permeable with the
exception of the access first five
meters of the access that would be um
sorry they would be permanent wall that
would be imperable in terms of the
access five meters because uh it would
be a concrete apron uh or similar
that's that bit in terms of the emerging
joint local plan
we do have policies in respect of
protection of biodiversity and
designations lp 18
rings a bell if i double check i'll find
it in a moment um
you just give me a moment i will just
check that
but
and then we've got the um and ultimately
the
national planning policy framework
picks up on
enhancement needed for biodiversity and
um protection of
ecology and biodiversity pretty much
throughout the document um for virtually
every type of development there is so
it's part and parcel of your general
considerations in planning terms uh
again if i need to pick out specific
paragraphs like i'll have to go away and
do that for you
um
thank you for that thank you chair on um
i'm just looking at the nppf paragraph
175b
and it says development on land within
or outside
a site of special scientific interests
of triple si which is likely to have an
adverse effect on it should not normally
be permitted so
but i just wanted to get a
understanding
um
from you because and it talks about the
benefits must clearly outweigh the
impact but
um that's just something i picked out
but i wanted a kind of planning
specialist comment on that thank you
unfortunately as all things it comes
down to the judgment of weight
we're judging this in our recommendation
to you that it has an impact we're
saying though that he's not an adverse
impact to warrant refusal that is an
opinion and a professional opinion and
obviously we've taken that opinion from
consultation with ecologists
as part of the consideration of this
application
if members feel opposite to that that is
your debate
you have sue here
if we've got questions later on
councilman thank you just a little more
about some suffolk wildlife trust
i can understand the borehole that can
be dealt with
but their second holding objection um
fragmentation possible damage to
wildlife corridors
how can that be dealt with that's a
holding objection
um the
ecologists have said that isn't the case
does that holding objection um just
carry on in perpetuity or do we how does
that deal with
in planning terms they're not a
statutory council team right so
they have a third party one we give
considerable weight to if i'm honest
because they are experts
and you know so you can possibly comment
more on that but ultimately that is
their opinion all right okay
thank you sue do you just want to come
in at all on any of the points you've
heard
um
okay um
who anyone else like to come yep cancer
food
yes couple of points um
there was question about the the site
apparently relying on um
solar cells and battery storage and
questions about whether that was
adequate and whether we have sufficient
to ensure that uh
some form of fossil fuel based
generators were not used to the
detriment of the
environment
i suppose the same issue goes for
a lot of reliance on wood burning
appliances and
fire pits
and the issues of the pm 2.5 that that
sort of process generates so
we're looking for a view on that
and the final one really the uh the
consultation on on the um
sewage deposit treatment plants
there's a considerable comment that um
the form of trade of well storage that's
being used
and uh
removal of material offsite has
considerable problems and is very much
not not a preferred route
and i wonder just how we argue that this
is the right approach
there was a fire pit proposed as part of
the application in terms of it's shown
on the plan
i have no idea what a fire pit spills
out in terms of its
carbon and other gases
in terms of
the there's no intention i don't believe
for wood burners within these units
um
we have nothing proposed as such that's
to say that there's nothing stopping um
that alternative being
a suggestion you know if
the solar panels and other alternatives
fail there is no reason why an
alternative
couldn't be pulled onto the site that we
we have nothing in here to stop that
unfortunately we we're into this
position we're planning where we have to
sort of have reasonable judgment of what
is the likelihood
um
do we put a condition on that no
alternative
in terms of wood burning or
diesel generator
he's put on site that's within your
power
whether it's reasonable
that's the debate
so i can't help you i don't think on
that one
okay counselor plasma
i'm sorry you're coming
uh beyond the application because i do
apologize for taking this over this week
uh to present it i would have to go away
and have a look at to see what that says
and come back to you but everything is
in the papers is all we have we have no
objection
in statutory terms to that
if it's the best approach it's a matter
of debate as well
thanks very much matthew one of the
questions i wanted to
we'll need some clarification on please
four units i see their single bedroom
but of course i think we've all been to
stay in places where you have put you
ups and all sorts things i mean how many
maximum visitors could there be you
could have
friends come and visit you for the day
etc without getting it going over the
top but i would have thought in a
sensitive site like that that is
something that needs to be considered
carefully so if you have four units and
you had a couple say with a i don't know
young child or whatever it happens to be
could be two or three in each one
that could have a bearing i'm not saying
it will or won't but is there any idea
about that and i can't imagine you could
condition it that you can only have one
visitor or something because apart from
that i can't see how you can actually
enforce it anyway
and would it be reasonable probably not
i think that's the point really
ultimately the number of bedrooms are
there how many um
in terms of visitors
you could put a condition that says only
those staying on site should be on site
um the biggest problem with that is as
reasonable as that may sound is is how
do you generally monitor and enforce it
um to say that
you have to station someone outside and
check everybody in you we do have um
we have often used a condition which
says you have to record the
names and addresses of all those who
stay and visit the site
but
again
the enforcement of that is is not overly
brilliant to do it's difficult to do so
i i get your point but
something like this i would imagine that
you would perhaps get the uh the chances
of a visitor
to a holiday maker
it might happen it could happen but i
think it in terms of likelihood would be
probably not that likely you know once
and once every now and again uh would
that be enough to damage
the site and cause a concern in planning
terms i don't think it would but you're
to judge
that okay thank you yeah council mayor
and councilman
so i noticed one of the conditions um no
cycle storage or use within development
i'm slightly surprised to see that in
the um
whilst
the ling may prevent or
maybe illegal to use bikes on the ling
is it
justifiable to say that you can't bring
your bike with you you haven't said no
horses
or anything else
[Music]
um
did that come from play services to that
point or was that
i don't know
as i understand it the the point there
was that if you're going to have
a holiday use within a cent a very
sensitive area
such as this
to encourage
lots of bike
riding across the ling and and elsewhere
is probably going to do it more damage
than just a normal walk around now of
course people can just go to the link
and use their bikes anyway
but to actively uh encourage that the
point here was to try and
manage the site to such a specific uh
holiday maker that they are very
sensitive to the the rest of the uh the
area
is it reasonable
i think if you lined up a number of
planners we might have different
opinions um but that is the proposal
before you we think is reasonable in
this case
that's a maths
thank you yeah
um just looking at slide 7 page
153 which is is the um site layout and
so on and and this this question that
the um suffolk wildlife trust is
particularly concerned about the
potential to fragment
habitat
bearing in mind that the rivers the
biodiversity corridor et cetera et
cetera and i i see actually that two of
the four lodges are right by the river
um so i am um
you know a puzzle puzzled as to how the
there is
there is not at least
a fair amount of risk of what they're
concerned about actually um
actually happening if these units are
regularly in use
i'm not sure that's a question
or a matter of debate
about this
it's very specific
fragmentation of
corridor biodiversity corridor habitat
um
but it's not the entire corridor you
know obviously the the
the corridor is wider than this site um
if we go you come out wide and look at
the entire uh river corridor and how it
integrates together
ultimately this is an intrusion to that
corridor in part i i will certainly
agree that
but
the point is weight of how adverse an
intrusion is it
to warrant refusal and we are on the
position that it's not
over that line to such an extent we
think we could just justify a defendable
appeal ultimately
okay thanks very much well we've we're
going to have uh two parish councils
speak now um so we have power grave but
because it's borders royden we've agreed
to have both i've agreed to both can
have their three minutes
so first up uh from palgrave we have
council val padney welcome
you have three minutes and this is the
timer thank you chairman
our main objection is a fundamental one
this is a green development in a very
environment environmentally sensitive
location
it's outside the settlement boundary of
nearby villages of palgrave dis and
roydon
it is in a special landscape area and
it's right next to an ssi which is
worthem ling and also ryden fen nature
reserve
if approved it would set a dangerous
president for development along the
waveney and indeed all along river
valleys in suffolk
if this development is approved why not
another one in the next open space along
the river and then another
and then others downstream along the
wave knee
we do not object on principle to tourist
related development so long as it is in
the right places the planning system is
there to focus on the right places
within settlement boundaries
outside special landscape areas
after all if we develop those special
landscape areas why would people still
want to come and visit them
design policy cl2 requires any
development in a special landscape area
to be sensitively sensitively designed
with high standards of layout materials
and landscaping and we do not see
adequate evidence of this application
particularly regarding the materials and
re appearance of the huts
air pollution and the development is
billed as off-grid this may be
well-meaning effort to appear low impact
and green but is in fact it is the
opposite the management plan reveals
that without electricity or gas the
residents will be cooking on wood stoves
along with using a fire pit this will
require high
fire raising by
inexperienced tourists for every meal
resulting in poor efficiency and high
smoke pollution throughout the day
much higher than domestic wood burners
affecting both the immediate area and
the people of dis itself which is right
downwind
this is completely unnecessary health
and environmental impact
in the rest of the country the
sustainability goal is to electrify
everything transport heating etc because
the electricity grid is the cleanest
source of energy in both climate and
health terms
this development is going in the wrong
direction
we have other concerns in our written
objection damage to the ling from
cycling non-compliant vehicle access
and others but i don't have the time to
cover these now but i would like to
point out that the neighboring parishes
of royden wertham have also objected to
the proposal for similar reasons and we
hope that we will be listened to
thank you
thank you very much i propose to have
both parish councils speak and then take
questions uh together so
next up we have uh royden parish council
and we have jane jennifer to speak on
behalf of roy
just give me one minute just so the
timer runs through
just it's getting there 30 seconds
okay over to you when you're ready
thank you chair
the southern parish boundary of royden
is south of the river waveney
along the former route of the river
along its northern bank are five royden
dwellings that many erroneously assumed
to be on worthem link from riverside
cottages to the west to riverside house
to the east
the parish boundary then continues east
along the entire north boundary of the
proposed ling road development under
consideration today
this site therefore directly about our
parish
in our submitted objection to this
development
roydon parish council fully endorsed the
views put forward by palgrave parish
council
and highlighted three specific areas of
concern relating to royden parish
environmental flooding and fire hazard
in addition royden parish council
supports the paper tabled on the 17th of
august by royden resident gareth
dalglish in which among other things he
examines examines and challenges the
decisions by natural england and msdc's
own
internal ecological advisor to not
object to the scheme
it is remiss indeed for natural england
to miss a the proximity of royd and fed
and not consider the impacts upon it
b the severine of the ecological
corridor between worthem ling and royden
fenn
c
the damage created by increased
recreational disturbance on worthem ling
and d
its own support for royd and fenn to
become a triple s i to include the whole
peat body and its immediate catchment
which would include the application site
the value of ryden fenn and its
surrounding areas as rare and essential
peatland cannot be overstated
the focus should be on their restoration
to increase the potential for carbon
storage and as a natural provider of
water regulation
suffolk wildlife trust submitted a hold
in objection on the 2nd of september
citing concerns over the severing of the
ecological corridor and the damage that
may be caused by water abstraction from
the proposed borehole on the surrounding
area and the roydon fence priority
habitat
royden fenn is hugely valued by local
residents in royden and surrounding
parishes as is worthem ling
our priority should be to protect and
improve these habitats
rather than threaten any deterioration
in conclusion ryden parish council
continues to object to the proposed
development
and we urge you to refuse planning
permission
thank you chair
thank you thank you very much do we have
any questions for the two parish
councils at all for members yeah cancer
event
thank you thank you chair i don't
specifically have a question for them
but it's raised a question that um
um hopefully the our ecological
consultant can help with um
the
firstly the royden um fen potential to
become a triple s i could um someone
um
i'd wonder if we know whether that is
due as it were or about to be made
because i think that would have a
obviously a big impact here and secondly
the pete um
the issue regarding peatland
and
the fact that i'm assuming this area is
is effectively part of that peatland
setting as it were and what was the
impact of the the sort of sewage system
proposed and the borehole on that thank
you very much
thank you chair um
i hope you can all hear me um
the first thing i noted down was whether
natural england were likely or had any
intention to designate
royd and fenn as a triple s i it's
certainly not something that is listed
as a proposal
so
sites
that are proposed for designation are in
the public domain
it's not one of those
um
i am unaware of any proposals however
given that it's a wetland site it is
part of
um
the little ooze and waveney valley fans
as they sort of exist in terms of this
is a remnant habitat um it may be a
proposal i'm not aware of anything
that doesn't mean to say that natural
england aren't considering it
maybe their peatland specialist is i
don't know
um
you then
made reference to the peatland body so
that's the area of peakland which to my
understanding is like it could be all
the way down the river
in its immediate sense in the bottom of
the valley itself as opposed to silts
that may sit on top i'm not a geologist
so i can't answer that for definite but
obviously if you've got a wetland
habitat
a finland habitat that relies on water
coming up from the peat
that's likely to be bigger than the area
that's actually shown on a map where the
habitat still exists where it may
formally have been all the way along the
valley
and obviously a wetland site
is sensitive to any loss of water and
i know some of the wildlife is just
concerned in terms of the bull helm but
environment agencies have not provided
any statutory consulting comments on
that issue so i again i'm i'm not a
water specialist so i can't answer if
they think that's a significant concern
or not
thank you very much thank you for that
yes counselor
actually i just wanted to pick up on
sue's point there because i find it very
disappointing to say the least that the
environment agency has not commented on
about water abstraction we've just had
one a hell of a dry spell
and i think if i've got them my memory
may be fading of course but i think was
it at red gray fenn they actually had to
flood it to bring back was it the great
rash spider if i remember correctly a
few years ago
and i am
really concerned the environments
agencies just talked about foul water
drainage and not these other issues and
it's been so dry up until last night of
course or yesterday
and compromising wetland habitats i
don't know if there's any artesian
effects i actually am not a geologist
but i i think it's pretty poor the
environment john just comment on the
environment agency
we've written to them they just haven't
come back so
yeah which is yeah okay
yeah cancer burn
it's a question yeah
it's a question i'd like to ask a uh
royden parish councillor
um um
given mrs houghton's response regarding
uh
her lack of knowledge of of
any natural england
uh potential designation for triple si
on what basis did you make that
statement when you mentioned it a few
minutes ago
i was
quoting from gareth douglas's
paper tabled on the 17th of august
which cites
the
issues that i went through one by one
including
natural england's own support for royd
and fenn to become a triple si
okay well we've that paper's been tabled
and uh mr douglas is uh speaking as an
objector so we could follow that up then
council madison
thank you yeah i i was
rather struck by and
curious about
the um this is in the palgrave
um
objection number four
um the site is owned by south norfolk
district council and managed by the
suffolk wildlife trust
and um
so i'm finding it very difficult to
reconcile that with the um
the wildlife trust um
holding objections and so on
can anybody substantiate that that is is
correct and what's the relationship
between those organizations and the
applicant
i can confirm that royden fenney is
owned by south norfolk council and he's
managed under an agreement with suffolk
wildlife trust
as agreed many many years ago with
norfolk wildlife trust
if that answers that part of the
question
thank you chair
i'll very briefly summarize the points i
made in the paper i tabled to the
committee meeting on 18th august which i
understand you've now but very recently
just had sight of
uh my relevant expertise is i worked for
40 years both suffolk wildlife trust and
natural england
and as a manager and naturally i managed
teams who responded to planning
consultations such as this
and i've known and lived in the area
since 1982.
your planning committee report states
the site is in proximity to recognize
wildlife areas and therefore the
potential harm to nature consummate
nature conservation interest of these
areas is of paramount consideration
and paramount presumably means overrides
the other considerations
it concludes in summary none of the
ecologically related technical conci
consultees object to the scheme
and therefore we do not consider a
sufficient grounds with whole planning
consent on ecology related matters as
you've already heard from your planning
officer today that's actually incorrect
the suffolk wildlife trust as a
technical consultae has objected
and you've already discussed the issues
around that
it points out that the site lies
directly adjacent to the river waveney
county wildlife site
forms part of an important ecological
network which stretches along the river
waveney uh connecting up sites like
royden fenn wertham ling and the other
valley fans like redgrove and lopham it
states that we're concerned these
proposals have the potential to cause
the fragmentation of this habitat and
therefore cause damage to wildlife
corridor on a previously undeveloped
stretch of the river
the point is this where them ling and
roid and fen are small fragments
of the habitats which once existed in
this valley much of which have been
drained destroyed and fragmented
protected sites like these are not
sustainable by themselves in the long
run
as the climate changes species need to
be able to adapt and migrate and it is
imperative that we start to rebuild
these ecological corridors not to
develop them
once developed the ecological link
between these sites is severed
we have a governmental england national
peakling strategy which speaks about
recovering
these lost peatlands those peatland
soils are still extant
throughout the valley and may include
part of this site
in my paper i also take issue with the
natural england response my colleagues
will be very happy about that
in the past natural responses were
written by experienced staff who knew
the area well unfortunately because of
budget cuts they're turned out by junior
staff in a national team and crew who
rely on a limited desk-based assessment
and don't know the context so the ne
response doesn't even mention royden
fenn hasn't spotted the potential harm
from increased recreational pressures on
worthem ling and is ignorant of fact
that its own national putin expert who
i've been in discussion with uh supports
designation of roy and fenn as an ssi
which would include the wider your time
is up now so just the final sentence if
you wish yeah so
in summary this is not a sustainable
development you cannot rely on the
natural england response to inform your
decision um it doesn't enhance
biodiversity and it limits our ability
to enhance biodiversity i'd like a chair
thank you very much uh questions do you
just want to answer the question that
counselor burn posed earlier about why
uh in terms of the
the uh david the going from your
question earlier
help me out i'm getting my i'm getting
my ssis and my all the others muddled up
tripwire so i was muttered up okay okay
it was just so i wondered on what basis
the statement was made by ryden parish
council that that
there was
some
possibility of
ryden fenn becoming
being designated as a triple s i thank
you yes i've been in correspondence with
ian dayak who's the national peatland
expert for natural england since march
of this year
about the need to revise ssi designation
throughout the wavelength little ooze
valleys and include royd and fenn and
he's very supportive of it i have
subsequently met david white the any
senior adviser on protected sites and
andy miller the senior advisor for
nature recovery from the area team met
them on the 14th of july where we
discussed the process we'd need to get
go through in terms of providing
evidence to support the notification
okay so it isn't proposed at the moment
but it's certainly under consideration
and supported by the national expert
thank you any questions other questions
for the objector
yeah
um
the the
extent of the peatland
uh in in that area
um
does that have an effect on the um
uh
the sort of natural flood control
um
that that can take place
around the ling and around the fen
which in turn will have i think i think
that question isn't really objective
because
i think if that question would have to
be for sue if anyone i i'm not sure
i i think i think it's just on the
speech that's been given
well yes but the um
did mention the water content of
peatland and i i
i wonder to what extent that has uh i
think the water content okay we'll allow
it but we've got to be careful we're
crossing into expert our expert sue is
our expert here on the matter today
well i'm also happy for uh
if you can answer the question that's
fine
thank you david yeah i mean
the there is superficial treatment of
misunderstanding of the flood risks in
the committee report and i do go into
this in the paper i've
um i've tabled
so i won't go into the technical detail
i put in there but the the key point is
this
people's houses and businesses have in
dis have flooded in both the last two
winters and such flood events are likely
to be more severe and more frequent with
climate change we're not we're not going
we're not good that's a statement you're
making on stuff though okay
we'll call it a day for the people
we'll call it today okay thank you fine
that's fine chad thank you uh
councillor madison
yeah um chair i i i would actually
request 10 minutes to read read mr del
glich's paper properly um
if i if we had it a month ago
i might have read it then but i'd really
like to read it now frankly
come back to that
any
any other questions i mean it was tabled
this morning at about 10 to 10
um
so
which is quite common for late papers
but we can give you time to read it if
you need it
any other questions for the objector
nope okay so we'll move on to the uh
applicant and we have the agent who's
going to speak sarah roberts over to you
in three minutes please
thank you
uh as summarized by the officer there
are no planning reasons for refusal
identified by the statutory consultees
we've included in the proposal all
possible steps to mitigate against harm
to the environment and the principle of
the proposal is low-impact eco-tourism
the draft management plan
which is forms part of the
application
forms the basis of a welcome folder in
the cabins which lays out reasonable and
responsible use of the site by the
visitors the final version will be
approved through planning condition and
can include specific notes the committee
requires
for example we are confused by the
suggestion that cycles are damaging to
the environment and should be excluded
from holiday makers approach to
sustainable holidays
cycling is prohibited off-road in the
ling yet the road is part of the
national cycle route number 30.
i'd ask the committee to confirm their
requirement in this regard cycles or no
cycles
it is expected nowadays that people will
try to take the train as a more
sustainable method of transport than a
car
the site is close to this train station
and therefore train and cycle is surely
moving towards a sustainable transport
solution for staycations
to address some of the questions that
have been raised there's no hedge loss
for access because the
road frontage is set quite a way forward
from the hedge
the surfaces inside the site will be
permeable for drives turning and parking
wood burning stoves are in fact proposed
within the units at the moment for
heating and cooking
wood fuel has now to be certified
by law to be kiln dried and so um
shouldn't impact on the neighbors we
would be happy to accept a condition uh
forbidding fossil fuel generators
a cesspool on an off-grid site is
considered the most ecological removal
of foul waste
and there are papers by the center for
alternative technology confirming this
as it is regularly removed and added to
the main system which again by
ecological bodies is considered the most
environmentally friendly way of removing
of dealing with foul drainage
we are happy to emit the fire pit if
that's considered to be a particular
problem and
[Music]
ban the use of open fires on the site
and we're also happy for a condition for
the borehole detail
to be approved
to be presented and of course there will
be environmental
environment agency approval for that
so
for any other questions i'm happy to
answer them okay thank you very much any
questions for the applicant
yep counselor ben
[Music]
on the borehole question
um
it's not inconceivable i would imagine
for for there to be
unsatisfactory results for that uh and
for the investigation
if if that were the case do you have any
alternative
uh means of supplying water to the site
yeah the alternative would be uh by
laying in a mains water pipe
from the
from the closest
by the by the water board
or anglian water here
you councilman matson i think you were
handling them
um yeah i i was um i wanted to
understand more precisely uh on the
the intention to use tanker um removal
of the um for foul drainage purposes um
the
they're very large um heavy
vehicles
and
what um
you know the roads that are proposed are
intended to not not impact
and to be permeable and so on and so on
um
can you just tell us um how that
contradiction is is going to be solved
um yes in our statement it's mentioned
about the road the access track from the
road
is existing it is comp it is a compacted
track it will be upgraded with hardcore
and gravel finish suitable for taking
the loading of a fire engine in line
with the
with the building control officer's
comments
so that would also
take a tanker
thank you
i'm following through on that i mean
what's the frequency
what's the frequency that the tank will
have to be visiting estimated at then
i have to see if i've got that in here
as well
i suppose i suppose to some degree it
will depend on the occupancy
waste
foul drainage
um
i i don't know what the i don't know
what the frequency of that would be it
certainly wouldn't be every week
okay thank you
any other questions yes
similar lines to the
um the bohol question
the supply of electricity is is by um
the solar panels
uh but but you
there is there is no indication as to
the uh capacity that you're uh
anticipating having to install nor
anything about the size of the battery
storage
um
if a similar question i suppose that if
if
it proved not possible to
supply sufficient electricity to the
site does that mean you would have to i
do plan on falling back on generators
[Music]
no the the nature of the cabins um is
that they're off-grid
and
we
they're designed for people who
want to want to have that type of
holiday and we would be happy to accept
a condition stating that no
generators will be put onto the site in
perpetuity because that's not that's not
the nature of the site the nature of the
site is that
it's it's it's like it's it's
effectively glamping that if you if you
get some solar energy which during the
during the day which you can use then
fine and if it runs out then you
you don't that's that's you then you're
back to camping
with perhaps
electric people bringing
hanging lamps or
coping without the electricity that's
the nature of the proposal
but but we'd be happy to have a
condition with no for no generators
thank you for that any other questions
yes cancer field
councilor ebern read a part of the mppf
which i'm afraid i don't have the exact
words
but which indicated that
developments adjacent to sssrs should
only occur in exceptional circumstances
what are the exceptional circumstances
for this development
the
uh the circumstances of the development
are that it is um it's very close to the
center to dis
which has a train station
it is providing um eco-tourism which is
a very popular means of holidays now and
um it's in a site which
is secluded and that it's got vegetation
around it so it's not impacting on the
landscape so in order to develop
tourism in the in the district
and in norfolk and suffolk
it's a good opportunity because it meets
a lot of criteria
for accessibility without using a car
as i say not impacting on the landscape
and the opportunity to to do a
development which is um
which meets economic development
criteria
without damaging the landscape
okay thank you so we'll now move on uh
to the ward member councillor byrne
uh
right thank you
jim um
i i would like to start off by
considering the positives of this
application uh it makes a contribution
to the tourism economy the area
as well as supporting the owners
business it has the potential to bring a
small number of people into the area who
might not otherwise visit
and who may patronize therefore other
businesses nearby
it adds to the variety of short-stay
accommodation types available to a
would-be visitor and it's a clear step
above glamping under canvas or yak skin
or whatever it is they glamp under
and in the very rural setting
uh
giving would-be visitors a choice is an
important component of the tourism
industry
at this stage one can only conjecture
whether the development would operate at
capacity throughout the year but it
might
and would therefore require pretty
constant servicing and management
potentially
creating a full-time job for someone
living fairly locally
since the application was submitted only
two people both
local businessmen in the hospitality
trade have sent in comments supportive
of the proposal
you
will now find these comments in your uh
late papers the table table papers for
this
meeting
um
but unfortunately submitted at the same
time the uh suffolk wildlife trust
holding objection letter was not
included in the
in the table
papers and it was
only
it was an omission on the
on the committee officer's part
not to include
mr delgadish's
august table paper this time round
because the application was withdrawn in
august the table papers for that meeting
should have been
included in in the table papers for this
one
um
[Music]
the uh
the notes of support one you'll see is
is from the landlord of the cocking at
fairgreen which is less than a mile away
very walkable is obviously going to be
of of assistance to that business
um
[Music]
the other one sent from sent to the
applications
applicant architect is from the owner of
the oak smear in broome now both
of those letters acknowledge that the
proposal could make a positive
contribution to the visibility of the
business
viability of their businesses and also
to others in the area
um
the owner of the oaks mayor
mir who declares he knows that mr hawes
the applicant
suggests that as his hotel accommodation
is always fully booked it indicates
there's an insufficient supply of
accommodation in the area
but if you know the oak smear i'm sure
you would describe that as a bit of a
non-sequitur or is it a choke and cheese
a more apt uh description
as with nearly all planning applications
however the key to making the right
decision is to cite the proper balance
between
the weight you give to these plus points
and the weight you give to the minus
ones
and in the present case i believe the
key to that involves accurately
assessing three critical elements
one is the ecological value of the
habitat and the extent to which it would
be impacted number two is the quality
and sensitivity of the wildlife present
in the area
and the extent to which it would be
impacted
and three is the adverse impact on the
local hydrology and the significance of
that over a wider area
about 27 public respondents have
objected to the application
although we are well aware that many
planning applications attract negative
nimby comments from the public
the standard of the one submitted for
this proposal is very high
and well informed especially on matters
concerning the natural
environment
as is usually the case these represent
representations are summarized in the
case office's report on page 103
in the form of a bullet point list of
grounds for objection consisting mostly
of two or three word phase phrases
there is no attempt to describe the
validity and planning terms of items on
the list which range from dog fouling to
adverse ecology impacts
regardless of how individually useful
selected ones might have been
in
enabling you to reach a balanced
judgment none of these representations
covered by the list are further
elaborated and none has been included in
the committee papers
it is therefore unfortunate the
community's views have been sidelined to
the extent they have in the case
officers report to committee
the general public's
objections are reinforced by those from
all three of the parish councils most
closely related to the proposed
development site that's palgrave of
course
royden as you've heard and worth them
and purgate to parish councils
ling road itself provides the obvious
direct connection between worthen parish
and palgrave parish
the western tip of the application site
touches the parish boundary
but uh ryden parish to the north is
arguably even more intimately impacted
by the proposal being separated from it
by little more than a ditch
with reuters uh royden fan ssi
just over 100 meters away
yet unfortunately royden parish council
was not
notified by us
however they heard about it and pointing
out the submission
they nonetheless submitted a
representation that fortunately has been
summarized in your committee papers on
page 98
statutory consultees responses are also
given in full on pages 120 to 145
not one from non-statutory council
teasers given except for the
suffolk wildlife trust
regardless of the relevant or quality of
content or credentials of the
respondent because of this it's hard not
to conclude that no matter how relevant
or expert they might be responses from
members of the public have to all
intents and purposes been ignored
for the all important ecological
considerations the officer's report
relies completely
on the consultation responses from
natural england
environment agency
place services
suffolk wildlife trust
and suffolk wildlife trust in uh the
earliest at the earliest stages
suffolk while i've just said tell me a
response if you've heard does not
include the officer's report and nor is
it referenced there
there are two
very important
comments
representations that i place a
higher store on and one is from dr
richard maybe
a writer and broadcaster who holds an
honorary doctorate from the university
of
saint andrews essex and east anglia he's
written more than 30 books between 1972
and 2016.
the majority of them botanical or
ecological in nature he's vice president
of the open spaces society and past
president of the norfolk naturalist
society
his credentials for me are fairly good
his submission
uh i won't read it to you except
he i'll read the last last sentence or
two many of us with an interest in local
conservation are looking forward to the
establishment of a continuous belt of
wild land stretching from ryden fen in
the east to national in the west
in accordance with the current
environment builds
commendation of wildlife corridors
the suffolk wildlife trust and the
little lou's headwaters project are
making steady progress in habitat
restoration and connection in the
western reaches of the eu's waveney
valleys
it will be tragic if there was a
backward step in the eastern region
needston reaches
um you've heard
gareth dalglish's credentials
um
40 years a professional ecologist
for the rspb suffolk wildlife trust and
a principal scientific officer for
natural england
so his credentials are pretty good in my
eyes and
also
i would therefore
place a lot of store in what he says
about about 30 seconds
our natural environment
is struggling enough at the moment
and it is crucial that we grasp every
opportunity to protect it and avoid all
temptation to exploit it without
extremely good reason
if planning is all about developing the
right things in the right places i find
it very difficult not to conclude that
however right this proposed development
might be in some contexts
in this one it is in the wrong place
in my opinion therefore the balance
indicates that it should be refused
thank you
um
okay members any questions to the ward
member
no okay um john did you need more time
to read that paper
okay so i mean i
uh how about just
five minutes does that give you enough
time
yeah okay
we'll just to give everyone a quick
chance who hasn't read all their papers
just so that you make a fully informed
decision
uh well just
literally 43 will kick off again
okay
everyone happy everyone had enough time
yeah i'm getting nods okay
good so we've had uh everything put
before us uh all the information
uh it's over with us to rediscuss debate
and come to a conclusion
um
who wants to kick off
castle war boys
yeah please
read through this um
it mentions
the flood zones
which are indicated on the the map
and it encroaches on it
but it
um
[Music]
and that is
flood zone one that's the zone which is
most likely to flood
but it says here
much of the site is in flood zone two
which is an area of land which is
not as likely to be flooded but
is flooded
or
there's a lizard so you want clouds
quite a high
probability of it being flooded and that
probability is increasing
john can you just clarify the flood
zones please probably be easier if we
could just put the powerpoint back on if
i can and just go back to the site
map the flood zones of two and three
which
ultimately in this case uh are the ones
we have to worry about
if i go back to
let's
go down
which way am i going let's go that way
get there right
yep there we go so um
as far as we have
got from the environment agency
everything is in flood zone one which is
most of the country
ultimately flood zone two and three
which are the
flood zones that we have to sequentially
avoid
essentially that part of the site is
flood zone three
um sorry two for the most part three is
further up but essentially in terms of
planning terms
the requirement of the mppf is to
sequentially avoid putting any
development within flood zones two and
three
so
we don't have well with the exception of
that path we have no development within
that flood zone but a path is not a
vulnerable use or engineering works that
we have to apply a sequential test to
as long as the physical accommodation
stays away from that area uh we can't
deal with it in a sequential terms
thanks very much thank you
okay so over to us discuss debate and
come to a conclusion
casamayor
somebody's gonna go first um
i'm not sure i've got enough information
to make a decision
suffolk wildlife trust have raised a
holding objection
they are
for information only but i think they
raise some
questions that again are highlighted
also by mr douglas
what impact will the boer hole have on
um
roid and fan we don't know
what about the wildlife corridor
and the
that corridor between the fen and the
ling
suffolk wildlife trust have issues but
natural um england haven't even answered
the question
so to my mind i i think we ought to go
back to them and request they do
consider those specific questions
and give us guidance and once we have
that guidance we might be we'll be in a
better position to make a decision about
this so
happy to listen to everybody else but
i'm mindful that we defer and seek
further guidance
counselor eben
thank you chair um i think councilman
has read my notes
despite the social distance we've got
um
um i i welcome ecotourism especially
very light touch tourism but i am
very concerned about the issues around
ecological connectivity we've got you
know this site is effectively bounded by
two very important
sites a triple s i and under moist and
then
and
you know i'm concerned that not enough
consideration has been made or we don't
have enough evidence or
a comment on the fragmentation of the
wildlife corridor and
the ecological
um aspects
and particularly um
with regards to sort of the peatland
area and the fact that
you know this effectively is a
much bigger area than just the triple s
i and and the
um the fan
and
i just feel we don't
we don't have that view on it and
particularly
you know i'm i'm concerned about this
borehole issue because if the borehole
doesn't happen then we give
permission
and they're going to put you know it's
going to be dug up to put pipes in for
water um so i think we we really need
more information on that and
the other aspect is the foul water
drainage i don't feel
confident in how that is being addressed
um
in terms of its impact
on the ecology of the area
so
i'm not happy about this application as
it stands
and
i would be
if if council mayor is
proposing a
deferral i'd be happy to second that if
that is what he's proposed but equally
i'm happy to listen to my fellow
colleagues
listening to what you're saying
my suggestion is not to defer would be
to refuse on insufficient information
ultimately
the matters you're suggesting would need
to fundamentally alter the application
before you
that's ultimately i think where you're
getting to
because fragmentation with a corridor
the size of the site is the size of the
site you know if you want to deal with
the fragmentation you'd have to reduce
the scale of the proposal before you
reduce the site area they are
fundamentals what is actually proposed
for you to be judged on its merits
so you may wish to look at it another
way which is to say that there is
insufficient information to demonstrate
to our satisfaction that the proposed
development would not be
detrimental to the valued landscape and
sensitivities of the ecology in the area
and i can help you further if you wish
on that
council you were next
maybe that's the way to go then in that
case because i i was minded to say if
nobody was going to say go for deferral
i would do that but having clarification
there from john about the way to proceed
um i just think it's pretty
reprehensible frankly that the
environment agency and others have not
answered the questions that's what
they're there to do that is their job
what is the matter with them because it
makes puts us as counselors in a rather
difficult position and
my knowledge of boreholes i mean when we
put one at one of the units many years
ago
i mean there was testing that went on
for a whole week extracting water i'm
not saying that happens now but i'm just
giving an example the practicalities of
this flow rates nevermind water quality
and everything else so these things need
to be clarified so if the way to deal
with that in order to get us to a
position to make us a proper decision
is to have to refuse it well then i i
would move that but i didn't want to
make the point at the same time
as i said earlier that one at henley in
my ward you know we do need to encourage
tourism and i mean eco-tourism is is
quite a an important part at the moment
so and so i'm certainly wouldn't want
that to be taken that i'm against things
like this per se because i just have not
um
and i suppose if it refused i would be
right and saying the applicant does have
a chance i know it's extra work to put
in a a renew application um without
further planning fees and so on i think
that's important to note um otherwise if
not that's why i would have moved
supported the idea to defer it because
we don't want to
penalize people unnecessarily
but that's that's my view so if it helps
to move refusal on the grounds of
insufficient information
then i'm happy to do that but i don't
know what everybody else thinks but we
need to get this resolved
my only concern with the suggested
course of action
if a subsequent application comes in
can we ask specific questions of the
environment agency or are we going to be
in the same position in a few months
time
ultimately the application before you
hasn't given you the answers that you're
looking for um whether or not we have
adequate consultation responses or not
if i go back to the environment agency
with a deferral or go back to other
parties i don't think i'm going to get
anything different to what i've got
before you oh the application is what's
been judged by them and they've given
you a response
can i just ask you a follow-up question
then following for that so if we do go
down the route of refusal
would the at the onus be on the
applicant therefore to go out and to get
the environment agency to comment and to
or to get independent and independent
view on that to then bring it back the
point this is the point we're getting to
is does this application and its
entirety of its proposal demonstrate to
you that the development would not
adversely harm this location and the
sensitivities of this location if you
are not convinced of that then that is a
reason for refusal perhaps perhaps
so we're blaming the applicant because
the failure of the you know the council
tease to do their job and that just
seems ridiculous
[Music]
ultimately your local planning party can
do so much and we there's responsibility
on other authorities to do their job so
in respect of water supply you know
environment agency angry water they have
duties to the environment as well and we
can't duplicate
those matters but if you're saying this
in principle this whatever we do here
this principle of application for this
site is always going to upset something
in biodiversity ecology terms or
landscape impact no that's what we
should no we're not we're just asking
the question we're not saying it's going
to do anything we want the consultees to
tell us give us the guidance as to the
impact it will have they said there's no
impact that is what's before you in the
committee report
they don't feel there's sufficient
impact to be to recommend to you to
refuse that is their position
and that position has been questioned by
suffolk wildlife trust and
other objectives so it won't be the case
i now have
concern
questions in my mind and i don't think
it's inappropriate to ask the consultees
to answer those questions hence my
original position then i need to know
precisely what question you wish to have
answered by the environment agency
sums it up quite well in his summary
with his first two points of his summary
you know
will it will this
development sever the ecological
corridor between ward and fen and
wortham ling and secondly will it
threaten the hydrological integrity of
roy and fenn
on those two questions the answer is
subject to an opinion because ultimately
you have this is you've got the location
of this development and its entire site
your judgment is does it sever his
opinion is that it does
their opinion is that it doesn't because
they have not given me an opposing
opinion to say this is a bad place for
this development sorry
not stating something is not an opinion
they have failed to give us an opinion
they've also failed to recommend refusal
to me
on lack of information if nothing else
so if we had no response from from them
at all that would be taken as as a green
line we have a process of determining
planning applications on their merits
and we consult and we have to we take
those into consideration that's what we
do this is what we've got
i can yeah don't get me wrong you are
fully within your rights to defer it and
i will see what i can do to get
something more out of the consultants
that we've got
yeah i'm going to propose deferral i'm
sorry i i i know i know that's not what
the officer wants but
there is no clarity around the server
well as severing the the corridor i mean
i think exactly as you've said those
first two points i'm not and the problem
is
we're taking no comment
as
uh
you're guiding us to take that no
comment as a positive and the problem is
the worry is that they just haven't
noted this and they haven't responded
and we have no confidence if they'd
actually written to you said we've seen
the comments and we have no comment to
add that would be very different from
them just not responding can i can i
just add one more point then if i may um
ultimately the starting point of that
question is what is the corridor how
wide is this corridor what does it
consist of how is it defined anywhere
which corridor we're talking about we're
talking about the interactions between
the fen and the xlsi or another
element
what is it the whole river corridor is
it everything within the uh
special landscape area by the way the
suffolk landscaping area in your
emerging joint local plan obviously is
going to get removed so there's
a combination of issues here
i need to context the question as well
as the question
and
i don't know how much we can do
to get anything more than what you've
got out of the advantage we will try but
i'm
advising you that i don't think i'm
going to be able to give you more than
you've already got in front of you and
we will be here again with pretty much
what we've got
that's nice
but i'm not trying to pressure you one
way or the other the decision is yours
how you go forward but i'm saying to you
the different options councilwood boys
thank you chairman uh thank you mr
papaji
um in my mind we've got
two professional witnesses uh i forget
the name of the first one you mentioned
uh councillor byrne but the second one
mr dog
who've
cast considerable shade on the comments
from our consultees in particular the
environment agency
they have they have scrutinized their
comments and they found them wanting
they haven't given us sufficient
evidence
to say that the
harm from this development
is
acceptable
and against the sort of sustainable
rural tourism which it claims to be
um
[Music]
i my feeling is that
the application should be refused
and if
the applicant wants to reconsider it as
the
sorry i don't know if you're the agent
or the
the agent has said that they could make
considerable changes to the
application to make it more sustainable
um
and i i seriously think the the
the environment agents should be made
aware of the
criticisms we are making of them and
their response and the adequacy of their
response
and give them the opportunity to
look at it
properly are you proposing refusal i'm
proposing mr
paytman g's
recommendation that it's refused
and there's the opportunity then for the
applicant to
redesign the application but there's
also the
i think the suffolk wildlife trust and
the environment agency both need to sort
of really
look at this in far more detail than
they have done it's not sufficient for a
chairman to give there's no objection
yeah i do apologize i didn't mean to
interrupt a councillor but if i'm
looking at the governance officer is it
right that we have a proposal and a
second donor yeah
so i proposed deferral and we've had now
a proposal for refusal so i'm not going
to ask whether we have a second
understood i thought that we had a
proposal under secretary to defer did i
i may have got that wrong though it's
i i didn't get to making a formal uh
fair enough i'm sorry
but i'm having a second jaws chair
[Music]
we've now got a proposal for deferral
and a seconder for the deferral and a
proposal for refusal so we have to go to
a vote first on whether we defer it or
not
yeah and then afterwards exactly then
we'll have to see where we go cancer
field
i was just going to
second council war boys proposal
we really i feel the the parishes the
professional uh
responses we've got from
mr uh
dal gliese particularly are very
persuasive
um i'm sure i read these at the previous
occasion when this was uh not didn't get
to our agenda but um
the the world members also made a
powerful
set of comments
all suggests to me that this development
should be rejected that we
have particularly bearing in mind that
the environment agency in natural
england's response
is severely lacking the the
it
it all seems to suggest they've just not
spent adequate time
considering this application at all
and we're really looking at
what is clearly the potential for
substantial damage to the um
the ling to the um
the raid and fan to the
river valley in general
to the
destruction of wildlife corridors a
whole range of things surely our
professional
advisors should be assuring us very
clearly are
not so that the
the benefit from the tourism does
outweigh the damage it's done and
they've clearly not done that at all so
okay well look let's go
let's let's go to the vote on deferral
first then if depending on where that
goes then we'll come back and if you
want more debate on the reasons for
refusal we can do that so let's just go
to the vote
to oppose the deferral effectively
that's your decision yeah that's your
decision
yeah so can we go to a vote on deferring
this on the grounds that we do not have
enough information put before us
to reach that decision
let me just put that reason for deferral
into the vote first
you
okay
okay members
that boat is now in progress thank you
is three votes four referral and four
gains for four votes against deferral
motion so that's lost so that means we
move on to the second proposal by cancer
war boys and sector by councillor field
for refusal can we just run through
those reasons so we're absolutely clear
please
if i can suggest to members and this is
a suggestion obviously for your
consideration um you may wish to
consider refusing on the following lines
there is insufficient information to
demonstrate the proposed development by
reason of its scale location nature of
use and range of activities is not
likely to adversely damage the sensitive
and valued landscape near and adjacent
to the triple si
nature reservoir reserves
and area in general and furthermore
would adversely harm and fragment the
cannot sorry the ecology the
tongue twister apologies i think i need
to put more stops in there give me a
moment
uh
yeah let's put that one in there
right furthermore
it would likely adversely harm and
fragment the ecological value of
ecological value
and connections of the area and it would
be contrary to policies cl8 cl9 rt19
rt16 and cl2 of the local plan 98 cs5 of
the core strategy and the nppf including
pretty much most of sections 15
conservative conservating
one of those days today conserving and
enhancing the natural environment
should i read that one more time because
i don't think that was very clear was it
it's all right for me but
i think we're there i mean house of war
boys are you happy i'll send it to
claire yeah and councillor field are you
happy as the second okay i think on that
basis we'll go to the vote on that i'll
send it to claire just a second direct
so you can put it into your system for
you bear with me one moment there's this
option
it would
right okay i'll send that there he goes
that sounds a bit more sensible
that should be with you claire to put
onto the system
thank you members
that vote is now in progress
thank you so again with councillor burn
abstaining that's five votes for refusal
and two against
sorry uh
mr that the coffee platform obviously
closes in 20 minutes so what i propose
is we take a break now but really start
again in 15 minutes so at 25 past where
we'll do the next application before the
two o'clock start for the afternoon
session so can we be back here at 1 25
to start sharply 125.
thank you
okay welcome back everyone so the next
application before us is dc 2103 207
in
summersham and hand over to alex bredman
who's going to take us through the
application
lovely thank you chair um good afternoon
members um
yeah so today i'm going to be taking you
through application number dc21
this is a householder application for
the erection of two-story rear extension
and creation of additional parking and
from uh
and sorry parking bay in the front
garden
and the site dresses hens croft 14 black
on close and summersham
there we go
um yeah so here's an error review of the
site obviously being a householder
application dd dwelling is existing in
amongst an established residential area
in the village
with a wider view of the site you can
obviously see
again more neighbouring dwellings and
some agricultural land to the rear
this is the site location plan provided
by the applicant um
two things probably to know is uh
obviously
i'm getting used to this mouse the
allotment gardens here obviously
not quite in date there is a new
dwelling there that i was approved in
late 2018
and another man of this this road also
now extends here to serve that dwelling
this is the constraints about the site
obviously you can see the built up area
boundaries that run
along here the site is within the um
defined settlement boundary of summation
and there is a footpath that runs down
the left-hand side of the site but
it's not within the site and and will
not be impacted by the works
uh here are the existing elevations
we'll look at the extension first
obviously you can see here this is the
rear of the of the dwelling we have
these two gable end features at the back
keep an eye on the right hand side
as you can see here the extension is
going to come forward from that right
hand side gable um it's going to be in
keeping with the form of the existing
dwelling
utilizing
essentially matching materials in all
areas also utilizing again we had a
a window at first full level
on the existing dwelling we're just
essentially carrying that forward with
an additional bay
no side windows though although they do
have the two additional roof lights as
well
existing floor plans
and then again pushing forward we have
the extension down here extends just
just over 3.6 meters from the existing
dwelling so not significant in scale or
size sorry
and then again coming over to here this
is where we have the new additional
parking bay
measures i think three point
sorry three by five meters
the existing parking area you can see
down here down the right hand side of
the dwelling
can fit approximately three cars on it
and the materials used for this
additional bay are going to be paid
block paving slabs to to match
again just another view of the entire
site now with the with the works you can
still see that there's going to be
sufficient
amenity space to the rear
and then lastly just a few pictures
and this is from the obviously the
highway the front and eastern side
elevation
and then again we have
the existing parking area with the
carport just behind
i don't have a final recommendation
slide but the recommendation i'll see is
to
approve this application in accordance
with details in the committee report
thank you
thanks so much do we have any questions
yes castlefield
yes just just to be clear
the uh
the park the um
carpel the parking uh facility at the
moment that that's attached to the
adjacent dwelling is it but belongs to
this dwelling
because it clearly interferes with it it
interacts with the host extension yeah
did you want me to go back to the just
to my embassy yeah sure so yeah no
you're right it does it's uh
don't need to go back there we go okay
let me find the right slide so you can
kind of see in there
it it cuts off
sort of as the the hip starts if i come
down to here so yeah there's a partial
sort of in the in the neighboring
boundary um
it is noted that obviously there is
going to be
some works just to cut off where that
roof is to i get i guess allow um the
extension to come in but that's not
going to impact the neighboring site and
that will still allow parking in that
yeah yeah
yeah there's no
it should at least one second if i can
find the right slide you can see there
you can still have the doors on the
front and then you should be able to
still get a car in there so that should
still serve as a as a parking space
if you guys can get the car in will you
be able to get out of the car won't you
well yeah good point yeah i i think so
highways have been consoled on the
application and had no reason for
concern they had no objections so
the second question was
i'm sure your view was that this is not
over development of this site
but it does seem to cover almost every
square foot so how much immunity space
is left
again if we take it back here you can
still see
there's a like a terraced area here
essentially the plans show that that's
going to be extended forward to roughly
here i don't have exact details of that
so that's not included
in this approval but then we still have
all this additional garden down here as
well which will be retained
so right okay that the additional garden
belongs to this dwelling then yeah yeah
that's all part of the site yeah
thank you no worries okay any other
questions
councilman yeah i i i also
looked at a little bit the the parkings
that the only question that arose really
um
presumably there's no issues about um
entering and leaving in forward gear and
all that uh because it's at the end of a
coldest sack is it
yeah again no i i think it's fine we had
we obviously consulted highways in that
regard and like i said there was no
objection so
we have to take their comments as it is
and assume there's no there's no issues
in that regard
okay no other questions so uh we don't
have a parish
council representative we don't have an
object we don't have a supporter we
don't have an agent but we do have the
ward member
casterfield
yes
to the to the best of my knowledge i was
present at a parish meeting when this
was discussed there doesn't seem to be
any objection
from
anyone
obviously the
the applicant is the chair of that
parish meeting but he was clearly not
present at the discussion and i heard no
adverse comments
um and clearly uh
personally i i
you've just heard questions that were
related to any issues i have was the car
parking in any way compromised the
existing one the answer to that seems to
be no
um
and was there adequate uh immunity space
left and the answer to that seems to be
yes
so i think i'm in support of this
application
any questions for the ward member
over to us to discuss debate and come to
a conclusion council possible um well
i'm perfectly happy with this chairman i
know that's come here because it's a war
member that's been through the proper
process and
john board member here has got no
objections at all so i would formally
like to propose that we do grant
planning permission
thank you do i have a secondary
council mathson thank you anyone else
wish to speak
okay can we go to vote this
thank you chair members that vote is in
progress
yes
thank you um that's seven votes four and
council of field is not voting as the
ward member okay
okay so the next application before us
we can't hear till two o'clock
uh because in the agenda we said we will
get to this one at two o'clock so
we'll just have to have a recess for 19
minutes
[Music]
okay everyone welcome back uh so we've
got our last item for the day uh which
is uh the application dc 2102047
uh
which is uh barley brick farm in
stradbroke and now hand over to john
pate mcgee to take us through the
application
thank you
so
the application describes is retention
of extension uh to agricultural building
approved under uh reference number 19 of
and this includes changes uh to the
building as a whole in terms of eaves
and ridge height
the building
is approved previously and
and sought to be for crop drying and
storage for agricultural purposes
so this is barley brick farm
so it's the site is located north of the
b1117
as it travels out of stradbrook and
towards lacks field it's located as you
can see on the aerial photograph in the
countryside clearly within a very raw
location of the countryside
very much as you would expect to find
agricultural use and set within large
open fields
so we have the the farm uh just there
and it's setting
and putting into context that's the
proposed site and you can see
the ownership in blue around the
proposed red line
we don't have many constraints
specific to this site um
list of buildings on there but i can't
actually see where the listed building
is
oh sorry the list of building
that is picking up on is i can't
actually move my mouse near it there it
is roughly there
and then we have the site layout
so the building that we're looking at is
the one on the right hand side
and these are the elevations so the
built dimensions of the barn
gives it a length of 61.2 meters
with a height at 11.5 meters and to the
eaves at
7.98 meters
obviously the approved dimensions of the
barns previously there's two
applications to refer back to open your
papers on page 280
so that's the floor plan
now
this shows us a google view of the
building uh when it was being built
essentially the first part phase or was
of the building
and the reality is that's what we now
have on site so this is in part and i
say in part a retention application
uh before us
and just to put that into context what's
there at the moment
all right
so that's all it's gone to the beginning
sorry
i can't reactivate it again
i'll leave that there
so
um
the
ultimately this is uh
an agricultural building before us um
comments from the parish council note a
number of issues thank you
particularly with the planning history
to the site
in assessing the larger barn
that was approved under the 2019
application they conclude that the
application should be refused owing to
the conflicts with the neighborhood plan
policy as trad 13 as if they consider
this would increase the traffic
movements particularly hgv movements
within stradbroke
while this policy applies to commercial
non-agricultural
uses the impact on highways for us as
officers is a material consideration in
any event
stradbroke is part of the suffolk hgv
network
and it connects to the a140
essentially the argument here is that
the presence of on-site facility for
drying in part would remove the need of
some of those traffic movements
so there's a bit of a balance between
it's a bigger building but on the other
hand it's saving traffic movements in
part as well so
it's balancing
the understanding of that um and whether
or not it is a significant increase in
traffic overall
we have found it not to be a significant
increase and no objection is found by
your suffolk county
the suffolk
county highways authority
we do need to consider the planning
history the approved building uh 2019
was an agricultural building it was
approved as a crop drying building and
there was no restrictions on that
building
in terms of level of use
number of hgvs or similar so even though
it's smaller its use
is unrestricted
this larger building we are now
presented with
if it is refused does mean the option to
build the smaller will go back to the
smaller remains available
and that is a consideration in material
balance
there are conditions on light noise and
these are followed through to the larger
building before you in your
recommendation
but your recommendation this time for
the larger building compared to what's
been improved before goes a little bit
further and there are four additional
conditions
on extra flaws
change of use or restriction against
extra floors change of use
we also see that goods that are dried in
this building are restricted to those
produced on the farm or for the farm
and we also remove other permitted
development rights and this takes into
account the suggestions of the parish
council and their concerns
and on that basis the recommendation is
one of approval
and if it was approved this would give
significant controls on the agricultural
building as proposed thank you
thank you
um just just for the monitoring officer
i've just
twigged that i know the one of the
owners of rataro farms but i haven't had
any contact with them for several years
but
i have in the past been in a room and at
various functions with them i think
that's probably declared as a long-term
interest now thank you thank you
um yeah council
well actually i could i could probably
say the same as you matthew but one of
the questions i i wanted to um just ask
john when you put here that you um
on the conditions the recommended
recommendations a restriction source of
goods to to those produced on the farm
how are you going to define the farm for
that because i think that's quite
important because i think
i mean it's not just that one particular
farm there could be others do you mean
within the same ownership or what what
exactly do you mean because you've got
to be careful how that's worded
at barley brig and it's associated land
not other farms in the company
so we would be determining
that i take your point there for clarity
i
would now this is of course the problem
with not being the case officer i
assuming the wording of that has been
defined further um and there's what
would be useful is what he'd have a plan
tied to that so can i
slightly make
an amendment which is a sensible
amendment to that which is to say
uh the extent of that is to be agreed
with the local planning authority in
advance
thank you
counseling
thank you chair um
it looks from the papers that there
that prior to
the bomb being erected and then the
extension to it being erected that there
was further hedging around the back of
the site
um and that's still that appears to be
no longer there
will that hedging be
reinstigated
um because it seems to be rather devoid
now of any apart from a bit of hedge
along the front there
um
will that be reinstated thank you
it's not the proposal before me but
further landscaping is an option if you
wish to condition it
that's a field
thank you um
on the traffic conditions i think the
numbers sort of imply
something like one hgv every four
minutes at
peak times i wondered
how that compares with the
traffic through stradbroke at the moment
whether you had a view on that
and the second question perhaps is on
noise
it just says
as suggested by environmental health and
the only comment i could find in the
papers was one that they'd
put i think it was 35 db
l a equivalent
but there was no time limit on it so it
wasn't a valid um
definition of noise so i wonder what the
current situation on that is
i don't have any information on what's
in scrapbook in terms of its the hgvs
going through there and obviously what
goes through strava comes from various
sources
and
seasonal probably as well
in terms of
environmental health
if you give me a moment i'll just find
their consultation response and the
condition they're recommending
but i've got to go through the whole
paper because i can't get there quick
i shouldn't ask this but do you have the
page number
so page 292 um
so
we have conditions on the
construction which
yeah so part of
essentially um
they want further information to show
the noise from the drying unit storage
does not have an adverse impact on the
occupants of nearby noise sensitive
premises
um
essentially looking for an acoustic
report
there's no set ah here we go so then
we've got
apologies let me read this brief with
again
we have
the following conditions noise lights in
terms of noise they're recommending
a limit of 35
db
but what they're saying is in terms of
the condition
we are looking to have a noise
mitigation strategy effectively
submitted to us for our agreement and it
essentially recommends that it would
look to achieve 35 db does that
make sense
any other questions anyone else
council war boys
uh yeah it's a question just a
clarification i
slide six
which shows the outline of the buildings
um
we talk about
retrospective planning permission for a
barn which does what does that apply to
on page 280 of you
you propose develop the application
seeks retrospective planning permission
does that mean the barn's already been
built yes
and which and that on page six that's
there's the cross there's a hatched barn
or store building yeah but if you just
grab the powerpoint
go down
okay does the store build it which
buildings
so the building that we're looking at is
this one here
the entire building entire building
part of which is essentially approved
under a previous planning application
but essentially it was extended hence
why we said retention of extension
and at the same time with the extension
as i understand it unless i'm corrected
later
at the same time the extension this roof
was effectively adjusted as well at the
same time so
part of the building if you like has got
full approval
the rest of it is essentially the
retention so the alterations and the
extension is for the is the retention
that's before us but we're treating it
as the whole barn in the context of this
application i see and the little bit of
the size the
the heat pump
that's already been given playing
purpose which has got permanent
so there's no further heat pump
development it's just going to be
heating the whole building
rather than part of it
uh that would so well that's for the
that's for the crop drying facility but
that would effectively cover the whole
building yes yeah
thank you
okay
thank you so uh we will move on to um
public speakers as another questions so
we have we've asked the parish council
adele
warden to speak uh
i'm sorry if i pronounce your name wrong
uh you have three minutes and there's a
timer here
you just push the uh one of them one of
the silver bit there you go and you're
on
thank you um my name is odile vladon i'm
the clerk of stradbroke parish council
there are two previously granted
permissions for this site one being a
large barn with no heating array
permitted the other being a smaller barn
with a heating array permitted
when granting permission for the larger
barn mid-suffolk issued conditions in
the interest of immunity and to allow
the council to retain control over the
development
the parish council maintains its
objection to this application and is
concerned about the precedent it would
set whereby an applicant could submit
two different applications then pick and
choose whichever elements of the granted
permission suits them best and ignore
those that don't
this is not hidden in this application
as both of the previous grants of
permission are referenced in the
planning statement
or that would then be needed once the
pick and mix building is finished would
be to submit a third application for
retrospective permission
surely planning policy and guidelines
are in place for a reason an applicant
should always seek permission not
forgiveness
stradbroke parish council notes that the
neighbourhood plan now in place had not
yet been adopted when either of the
previous applications were reviewed
stradbroke through its neighborhood plan
encourages development in the village
with up to 280 homes proposed
when preparing the plan the parish
council was mindful that stradbroke
continues to be a working village but
also noted the regular complaints
received from residents on traffic
issues experienced in the village and in
particular on queen street
which forms part of the suffolk lorry
route for access only
to this end the parish council included
policy strad 13 and its plan that
supports expansion to existing
businesses as long as that expansion
does not impact on the roads in the
parish
should councillors today be minded to
grant permission for this application
the parish council urged them not to
remove any of the recommended conditions
and would ask that they reconsider one
other condition proposed by the parish
council the condition for a limit on
working hours as this would offer some
protection to the immunity of the
neighbours and the nearby village centre
in particular the residents of queen
street ahead of the long-awaited and
eagerly anticipated review of the lorry
route proposed by suffolk county council
but yet to commence
i'm happy to clarify any of the matters
either with this statement or those
previously submitted and i thank you for
your time
thank you very much dude is there any
way of measuring the
the i'm just thinking when the traffic
comes out of the site
how much goes through strava and how
much goes the other way but i guess
there's there's no clarity on that it
could be going up here exactly
technically if you if you uphold the
conditions none of it should come
through stradbroke should it because it
should all be
sourced on-site dried on-site and used
on site
if you don't uphold the conditions i
mean that's assuming that the the
applicant does what they say and brings
their crops across their land
and doesn't bounce their tractors up
queen street instead
or new street
i guess it depends what the wider farm
means we need to just have clarity on
that i know which is what we talked
earlier okay any other questions for the
parish council
no okay so um we
do not have a objector we don't have a
supporter but we do have the applicant
to speak so stephen bainbridge over to
you and again three minutes please
thank you good afternoon chair and
councillors my name is stephen
bainbridge i'm a planning consultant
chartered member of the rtpi i've been
working on the planning matters on this
site since 2015 and the planning
commission for the ad part next door
this planning application is before you
in the format it is because the
applicant was determined that it'd be
done in a clear manner i reviewed the
officer's report before you and agree
with its principle recommendation that
along with other planning applications
at barley brig need to be approved
where we differ is on the application of
planning conditions the planning history
shows you that planning conditions have
been inappropriately applied on this
site in the past and the biogas plant
next door and subsequently had to be
removed or varied in order to work
better
at expense to the applicant and also a
time cost to your planning department
government guidance on the sparing use
of planning conditions is clear
contrary to government guidance
paragraph 4.3 of your report advises you
to apply planning conditions fettering
economic development to address concerns
turning to the conditions in your
committee report they are summarized and
not included in full
with the respective reasoning how this
is meant to give anyone certainty i
don't know
tackling them in turn and with reference
to the correspondence are asked to be
put before you
condition one that's a standard
condition that's acceptable condition
two on noise is flawed for various
reasons firstly it's a pre-commencement
planning condition for a development
which has been finished secondly it's
asking for expensive noise work to be
done which has already been done on the
site next door if you are to apply a
condition i would strongly suggest use
the one i provided which had an laq time
limit included in it as well
the third condition on lighting is fine
the next four conditions come direct
from the parish council are all flawed
for various reasons
the fourth condition is not necessary
because you have the first one but it's
going to have to be based on something
other than traffic reasons for the
traffic for the reasons are given before
the fifth condition suggests verbatim
use of condition 10 of the 2017
permission
but that's daft because that condition
prevents grain drying on the barn you're
recommended to approve for grain drying
the sixth condition limits the use of
the barn for drying but you can keep
this condition if you wish
but its justification is weak
the seventh condition concerns
restricting pd rights as you know
restricting pediatrics requires careful
and specific justification for which
we've been given none
the parish council want it applied
because of traffic impact which county
highways say doesn't exist so again i
ask what the planning reason for
applying that planning condition is
i'm happy to answer questions help the
officers out with the planning history
and what's been done and why
not least where it relates to
formulating legitimate and enforceable
planning conditions
happy to help do that now or work with
the officers after today if you instruct
them on the list of conditions that you
want
and those conditions clearly will have
to meet nppf guidance
and thereafter give certainty to all
parties thank you
thanks so much uh questions yes
counselor yeah just a couple um
first one regarding the movement of
traffic through the middle of stradbro i
think this site is i don't know i guess
it's what one and a half two miles from
the center of stradbroke
uh certainly a considerable distance out
of the center strap but how do what what
effect do you think it will have on
movement
be it with fast tracks lorries or
whatever through the middle of
stradbroke and then the second question
is a technical one um
what is the drying system here is it an
on-floor drying system because i take
your point about additional floors and
so on you need to understand
what the drying system is
because if you need a walkway above the
grain or something or does that
constitute the floor or not and you if
you get permission for this you can't
make it so it's unworkable
i know it's a technical one but yeah i
think you probably understand where i'm
coming from on that
oh good point
no problem um as far as the hgv
movements are concerned as you've been
told the
pre-existing barn the one that was built
was completely unrestricted so in terms
of that the the the
implications can only be comparable um
as you've also been told um strats on
the htv network um highways have said
there's no material effect so i would
agree with them and say that the impact
on strata will be immaterial
on floor so yeah the the drawings show a
gantry above the top and no first floor
inserted so if the first floor appeared
it will be contrary to approved drawings
okay just to check on this so we don't
get in the muddle
i hope the gantry would not count as a
flaw
it shouldn't but i'll defer to to mr
bateman g but i don't think it will
count as the floor it's clearly labeled
as again no no no i know but i just want
to want to be quite clear we don't end
up in the muddle
the
question here is if it's part of the
plans as approved fine
anything or whether it's a flaw or not
um the condition we're referring to is
any additional flaw
that
is proposed later on so um it wouldn't
be covered either way but you could
argue it's more part of the plant than
it is of law
councilman
um thank you very much chair um i'm not
sure i know you say you're trying to
do this in a clear manner but it it's
not very
clear and um it's a shame we didn't get
um
put this in
you know without having it to be
retained but there we are the um
with regards to the conditions obviously
these are conditions for this
application not for a previous one so
this is that's what we're looking at and
are you would you be
able to do i'd mention the point about
landscaping um and hedging and trees
would you
be happy with a condition to reinstate
some of that hedging and do some
landscaping there um and secondly um
would you be able to give a view please
on the um
[Music]
potentially
and i'm not suggesting we do it but just
what your view is of a time limit for
hours of operations
and
thirdly
the um
you said you didn't want to have a
condition about the removal of permitted
development rights is that right and if
so could you just give your reasons for
that thank you very much
okay thank you i noted four points there
um in terms of timing and the
regularization regularization's not
necessarily ideal but it's perfectly
permissible in planning terms we were
asked to
delay the submission of this application
until the previous one on the field
array was done i don't know if this
committee remembers but that application
was delayed for a long time partly by
covert so the barn has been finished in
the meantime commercial pressures so
the applicant apologizes for that but
had other world matters not delayed
things i probably would have been
sitting here a lot sooner potentially
before the barn was finished who knows
in terms of landscaping the applicant's
always been content with landscaping
conditions not least around the the
biogas plant et cetera there are already
specifications etcetera for bonding and
hedging and native species and the like
so it would just be a case of
transposing them
in terms of hours to be frank you can
apply condition limiting hours
but i've successfully removed one in the
past because officers agreed that
restricting agricultural use to anything
other than 24 hours was unreasonable so
to be frank i've just applied to remove
it again
and in terms of pd rights
um it wasn't a comment about not wanting
them removed it was more comment about
this being careful with the
justification for removing them because
the bar's quite high when it comes to
restricting pd right so it's just if
you're going to do it be clear with the
reasonings then i can advise the client
after the event what's been done and why
council field thank you
you mentioned that you have provided a
suggested
noise
condition
could you indicate what that is
the one in here is 35 db
i i think
the equivalent
what are you suggesting how does that
compare with
background noise levels
so do you have the additional paper that
i asked mr carmichael to put before you
that would answer the question if you
had it
whether we do or not if you'd like to
read it over too happy i'll read it out
yeah that's why
there was a planning condition on the
county um
planning permission for the ad plant
that is the one that the eho refers to
as being unenforceable because it didn't
include the time limit so i referred to
it copied and pasted it in some
correspondence and then inserted
a time limit on that that was in those
papers the one that i'm recommending
would read and it'd be identical to the
county one just with the exception of
that
insertion uh noise associated with all
components associated with the
agricultural crop drying barn hearing
approved must not exceed 35 db laeq 15
minutes at the nearest sensitive
residential property identified as brick
house and the reasoning given
immunity in noise
so the ad plant is conforming to that 35
db 15 minute limit and has been
monitored and successfully passed so if
the ad plant with its engines
can get under that limit i'm sure that
the dry environment with much smaller
equipment could could easily do it and
then clearly if it didn't well you have
enforcement powers to deal with that but
the applicant is content as it would
yes so from memory the ad plan at most
reached 31
so with the extra three you're still
under
uh councillor madison
thank you yeah
that the
slightly unusual circumstance is really
where the um
the applicant is actually challenging
quite a lot of the recommended
conditions and
i was wondering how how we might best
work our way through that and it felt as
if we needed a dialogue between
ourselves and the applicant and and mr
paytman g now we we've done some of that
um but i i
i still i still find it
quite difficult and
we may you know i feel as if we get to
discuss some of these things in debate
we may need to come back to the
applicant and and ask a bit more
um as it as it unfolds
um so i'm just expressing a difficulty
at the moment really than what you think
about
i'm not sure there's a question there to
be answered john
the committee is able to put any
conditions it so wishes it's up to the
applicant how they deal with those later
if you want noise conditions anything
else it's your it's your committee it's
up to you it's not up to the applicant
yeah
i'm saying that process yeah um that
that
you know
we need to work our way through these
one at a time
um
not a blizzard of of objections um from
the from the agent
and then we're going to get into debate
and we're going to um
[Music]
it's going to be not ideal as a way of
dealing with that's what i'm saying
okay
i was going to go on to the ward member
unless anyone else has got any questions
nope i'll get onto the ward member okay
so ward member uh chair of members
apologies for not attending it sorry
councillor julia flatman
um chair members apologies for not
attending in person unfortunately have a
previously booked council appointment
i'd like to thank daniel the officer for
the work he's put into this ongoing
application
committee b have already been privy to
bali briggs retrospective planning
activities
i'm disappointed that not all the
conditions that have been listed so
clearly by the parish council have been
included
however if members are minded in
granting the application
i fully support the
officer's recommendation along with
further suitable conditions the
committee consider fit to include
so that's it from the ward member
so yeah
we're into debate but also we can take
questions as well so
yeah straight off cancer
sorry this isn't debate this is a
question is that i it seems to me highly
unusual to have conditions that say as
requested by so and so we've never ever
never had that before i pick it out by
my pre-meeting we just want to put
brackets around that that's just
can we remove all of those references
because they could be requested by we
wouldn't put as requested by the
planning officer or as requested by the
agent so can we just please remove all
of those
um two points and then i need the third
point which i'll come back to chairman
about um first of all apologies for the
uh inclusion of as recommended by
australia
the formatting of that is clumsy and uh
particularly not helpful so i apologize
for that and i'll take that back as a
point um i'll go back to the noise
condition as well very briefly uh the
applicant is correct that it does
have a timing issue and effectively it
talks about construction when obviously
it's all done and dusted uh it would
need to be altered to be reflective of a
reasonable time period for compliance so
six months is probably where we'd start
with that
in terms of
another point can i possibly ask for
five minutes and i really apologize for
doing this but
yourself and our legal officer i just
have a clarification that i need to make
with you
so um something's just come to light
around the application uh which john's
just going to very quickly talk us
through um and then we'll i'll come back
as to what we're going to do next so
john overtube please
thank you
in respect there is
i'm going to press phrases ultimately
the format that officers have used to
recommend this approval
is and has been confusing um and i think
we need to add an apology for that so to
say these are requested by this fabric
parish council and therefore you refer
to what the fabric parish council say
and ultimately their wording is based on
their understanding of the application
it's not actually the recommended
wording that we will use as officers and
i think there is a
potential
risk of misleading you
in the context of what is actually on
the table as the proposal for officers
i think
ultimately what we need to do here is
take this away we need to actually have
the conditions in full
of what we would recommend in this case
and come back and present that to you
and given that there has now been a
suggested risk of challenge uh on those
conditions possibly food judicial review
or indeed through
a variation of
an application later or appeal against
those conditions if imposed it is
considered to be logical and sensible
for us to take this extra action and
give you a more fuller and correct and
justified account of these conditions
and on that basis we
are looking to defer this matter for
this time being
can ask a question please because the um
the agent has referred to a previous
application that wasn't heard by
the committee a it was heard by
committee b and and there's some
misunderstanding that
this committee would therefore have
known all the details of a previous
application that when things so when
anything does come back can it please
incorporate everything into one paper
and not expect us to have read the
entire planning history of this for the
last you know how many years thank you
thank you point taken
so on the advice of john and taking
advice from our
legal officer i am deferring this
application yeah john
yeah this this is this is on conditions
actually um i there was one thing i
wanted to to raise on the conditions
which if mr payment is going to take
them all away it would be helpful
perhaps that he took away this point at
this stage
but you can do it outside of this
meeting yeah i can actually that's very
true just as you wish yeah
okay um we still apparently do even
though it is the recommendation of our
uh the senior planning officer and the
legal advice that we defer we do need to
vote to agree to defer it so we will
just go to that vote please
yes thank you
thank you members
yes of course yes
thank you
thank you chair that's eight votes for
deferral
okay sorry about that we don't defer
lightly uh we don't do it we don't
normally like to do that at all if we
can possibly help it when something
comes up we need to take that advice
so we closed the meet there are no other
urgent site visits so therefore we close
the meeting at 2 42 thanks everyone